two
hello hello everybody and welcome to
another action-packed week of the H3
podcast it is Monday
it is Monday
that's right Gabe's least favorite day
but here we are we all got to do it
February 13th
welcome everybody we got a great and fun
show planned
you know was the Super Bowl over the
weekend sure was I didn't even know that
was I like Saturday nights when I found
out was the Super Bowl you're not a
Chiefs fan I'm big on the
under items
or I didn't I barely even know that
Kansas City exists
what state is in it
yeah I don't bro I I
was sleeping at the time
you know last night we were watching the
Super Bowl a bunch of us on the crew
together and we um
we were torn with the idea of playing
hooky today we were thinking about not
coming in really yeah just all you not
come in just ditching because the Super
Bowl was just so important yeah it was
so intense but like we don't want to go
work tomorrow let's ditch okay that's
why you guys didn't do that yeah we
decided we couldn't do do that to you
but
but maybe maybe in the future if there's
nobody here you know what happened
um
well I'm glad it's only once a year
hey hey who won actually I left at
halftime I actually don't know you left
at halftime and you didn't watch well I
always performance oh
right afterwards listen I was with my
kids at my parents house I was watching
the TV was probably like a good like 50
feet away small TV
that's how I watched that's the way to
watch baby uh the Chiefs won the Chiefs
in a fairly uh controversial ending
really in fact yes there was a penalty
that uh pretty much swung the game in
their favor so wow it's a close game
though so that it was that's nice at
least for the people that care there was
some there were some shitty calls made
if I'm being honest what was the last
minute call that wait is this an
arrowhead oh that's kind of the Chiefs
was that a little problematic they are a
Native American themed yes and uh
because like Kansas is the whitest
[__] on Earth uh well they're
not in Kansas
what Kansas City right
oh it's is Kansas City not in Kansas
not what state is it in
for all the marbles I don't [__] know
or oh is it in Missouri you got it oh so
it's still white ass [__] too
yeah that's good too we we the Chiefs
down here boy
come on now it's not as bad as the uh
Redskins at least the Redskins reskinned
they they reskin they're just like
Washington football now they're the
commanders now oh they're the commanders
yeah they rebranded again to the
commanders but like they got an
arrowhead like who are you honoring
exactly like are you
like
it's not really the message here well I
got to tell you uh I don't know if you
caught this but at one point in the
broadcast last night they were um
going around to you know various sports
bars around the world of uh Chiefs fans
that were watching the game you know how
they always do that and it's like here
we are in this place yeah and they were
hopping around all these places and then
they went to Dresden Germany to pop in
in a bar in there and the Chiefs because
they're the Chiefs they have this like
thing where they do like a tomahawk like
chopping motion as like their thing oh
[__] and so all of a sudden I'm just
looking at the screen it says Dresden
Germany and it's a bunch of people going
like this holy [__] dude that's awesome
what are they doing in Germany watching
goddamn Missouri football well they saw
the hand motion they were like oh this
is for us there's a bit of Hitler and
everyone that's true
I think I just put on a women's this
thing is not fitting that you're also
gently your neck is keying out as well
so it's a little odd let me switch
let me switch shirts I tried picking
something without any green in it so it
does and also very slight it's very
form-fitting
I will say that we are women We Are Men
[Music]
look at this yeah I know yeah
so the Chiefs won so what was the
controversial call
uh there was a it was holding right Zach
there was like it was something like
that yeah but it was like third and and
almost goal like they they were uh close
to scoring and then they threw an
incomplete pass but the refs called
holding on and they got first down off
of it and then right after that they
scored and oh there was also some shitty
calls uh and like the first half of like
incomplete pass like the dude clearly
caught it the eagle and I don't know I
just I feel like there might have been a
little a little cool okay all right a
little gobble ghoul yeah a little this a
little Gaba ghoul huh what do you think
with the button up should I button it or
unbutton it
you like I'm into the top button lately
but I can't say that I'm crazy about it
right now
like button
let me see by the way this is available
at teddyfresh.com
it will look better on you than it does
on me I guarantee it
I can but I can formally guarantee that
to you guys right now button this High
fashion space you carry
it's high fashion statement piece
could be years at teddyfresh.com
all right
I feel like scarce like the old scary
scream totally
[__]
all right Nick Clark thank you for the
red Kingdom I don't know what the [__]
that means that's the uh uh oh is that
Chiefs I believe so yeah okay
okay well congratulations to the Chiefs
and um
shout out to the Native Americans as
well who are sharing in the honor uh
Native Americans everywhere are
celebrating the victory
of the Kansas City Chiefs my friends
I feel this yeah yeah so uh oh thank you
to honey my God we love coming
yeah we got so much to talk about today
um
we got UFOs we got a huge Joe Rogan scam
dude this chemical explosion in Ohio
really isn't being talked about I was
listening to the Daily today expecting
to hear about that
they didn't mention it not even the like
more the more more headlines that you
need to know they didn't even mention it
yeah the um I saw that on all the Sunday
uh news shows as well
um why are they not mentioning it uh
that's a very good question I mean it's
not like it's a total blackout obviously
there are stories about it but um for
the scale and severity of it it
definitely seems like it's so and in
Ohio there was a train crash or
something happened with the train that
was transporting
vinyl chloride which is like an
extremely [__] toxic chemical yeah
and an insane amount of it
just watch this video I see I don't
wanna I'm not ready to go down this
rabbit hole but I'll just show you this
you know what no I'm not ready for this
Rabbit Hole okay
it's just toxic you got that right very
true but this these are rainstorms these
are these are toxic [__] clouds and
I'm no scientist but I think everybody I
was reading that everybody who basically
can even see these clouds is likely uh a
super high risk of getting cancer yeah
from just being in that close proximity
of the fumes not it's not good it's not
good folks
and I mean haven't the Palestinians been
through enough I I my heart goes out the
city it happened in is called Palestine
yeah
um we saw it in the clip the one that
you just pulled up actually the the guy
in the video who leaves a resident
pronounced how did he pronounce it a b
Palestine yeah Palestine oh I I noticed
that don't cater yourself bro you're in
Palestine
you know what I mean just accept it bro
Gaza is over at the the Gaza bowling
alley
the West Bank uh Union
it's all adding up
you know the checkpoint in uh yeah
but yeah it's uh you know just just like
a Chernobyl level event happening in the
midwest right now but who cares Super
Bowl Sunday baby do you think it is that
bad Chernobyl level these are I mean
it's obviously a different totally
different type of disaster but um I
don't know from what I've been reading I
mean people are saying it might be the
worst ecological disaster in this
country's history and it's not really
getting that much coverage and old
Russia there was that uh new uh nuclear
plant that blew up like what's the name
of that
you know what I'm talking about
something
that's Chernobyl you're thinking of
um okay let me just watch the damn video
then
does that include like the massive golf
oil spill worse than that these aren't
these aren't storm clouds
this is the [__] [__]
that they burn off the [__] [__] they
burn off and he's Palestine this is not
[__] storm clouds so apparently
they're trying to burn all the chemicals
that leaked which is like also insane I
mean I don't know what to do with that
[__] I I don't know uh enough about it
apparently the chemicals itself
is so [__] toxic it's better for them
to burn it than let it seep into the
ground well from what I understand too
the the it started burning on its own
from the derailment like there was a
fire from the train or whatever and they
were
concerned about it hitting the tanks and
causing like a huge explosion so the
they made the call to intentionally
release it and burn it in that way
um yeah I mean I have no idea if that is
the smart move it seems like it's just a
lot of bad options and maybe that is the
worst of a bunch of bad up I'm sorry the
best of yeah a bunch of bad options
do we know oh here let's watch this
look at it this is over Darlington
foreign
that he's sharing this but I also feel
like he needs to get the [__] out of
there yeah
he's fine
look at that weather tonight boy this is
their [__] success
that ain't no [__] storm cloud that's
the [__] [__] for me it's Palestine
I'm laughing because it's so [__] up
yeah
justifiably upset listening to the dog
barking is what's making me like
get the dog out of there they're about
to go hunt down those dogs like
Chernobyl
yeah I don't know I just wanted to make
it even sadder for you yeah thanks
devastated this chemical is vinyl
chloride it's used in the manufacturers
of numerous products and buildings and
construction automotive industry
electrical wire oh so it's very
versatile
depended upon heavily by the rubber
paper and glass people so it's used
quite a lot in a lot of Industries so
this [__] seems to be going back and
forth
across country quite a bit [__] kids
so quiet pretty ominous yeah I think
everybody's dead
it's too quiet we don't want to leave
already dude it's like the [__]
Homestead from
episode 3 of Last of Us
ain't nobody there I'm ready let's get
out of here
I wish we could get the [__] out of here
oh
[__]
you [__] greedy [__]
you could have [__] waited you could
have [__]
that's right you could have transferred
the contents
you didn't have to do this you did it
because of time and money that's right
right so that that that's exactly why
you did what I've been hearing which I I
don't know enough about it so know if
this is let's wrap it up boys let's set
this here on fire get on our way yeah
that they wanted to get the Line open
back up as quickly as possible and
that's why they chose to burn it
um listen here now boy that's true I
gotta be home dinner by 6 PM let's light
this here oil on fire and get on our way
now
mm-hmm
yeah so rest in
ashes there let's see and about so
they're evacuating everybody
this was February 3rd oh this is from 10
days ago yeah it happened like two weeks
ago and it's still they just started
burning it no no that the burning
started shortly after the accident but
it's there's so much of it that I think
it's just it's gonna take so that is a
new video because I saw that video
yesterday
yeah the uh
the whole Situation's super [__] I
don't know let's take a look here we got
some Drone footage
I work with chemicals and burning them
close to the ground is dangerous they
have to be burned out of tall flares I
also think it was police who made the
decision oh that's good thank you Goosey
now listen here my ah I'm trained
and I'm making the decision we gonna
light this here on fire I'm the chief of
police
is a de-escalation tactic sir I work for
the EPA I'm a doctorate in ecology now
you live in here you pencil pusher
I'm gonna light this here on fire and
get on with it
if you do that we will have to evacuate
the entire Midwest millions of people
will die now shut your mouth
I'm the sheriff around here
I'll light it on fire boy
get me some dinner
um fire
yeah I don't think that's a decision the
police should be making
oh my God that is a [__] huge train
wreck
yeah it was a massive train and
apparently I was reading this morning
that um it was not properly balanced
um which is what can cause this to
happen the level of incompetency is
insane it's beyond incompetency it's
honestly a lot of it is just negligence
too just people sleep at the wheel
um that are supposed to be regulating
this kind of stuff the policy that uh
probably directly led to this happening
was one of the main things that the you
recall just a few months ago they were
uh negotiating contract the rail workers
unions and our boy Biden sleepy Joe uh
basically forced them to accept a
contract well one of the things that
they were not able to get was removing
this policy that
made safety uh
way worse and then just a few months
later this happened so uh that's a big
game man not a good look Joe not a good
look the train unions were saying it's
unsafe
and Joe Biden said well tough fit out go
back to work because we need that vinyl
I think Joe I think Joe Biden needs to
go there and breed that air for a week
seriously yeah he needs to go [__]
just
filter it through his lungs for a good
long time I'm in bootage they should
both go down there smell the roses
yeah it's not good it's not good this
year trained about about balance to me
what's in it just the most toxic
chemical known to man a big lie
hey you got to make sure that the train
is balanced because you know
could tip over now this isn't about
balanced to me you afraid of a little
vinyl chloride I grew up around vinyl
I'm all right no problem oh man hurts
nobody it hurts everybody Joe benefits
everybody no no ghost economy no oh God
come on here now Joe Biden we we here
sniffing some Vinyl chloride here
nothing like wake you up in the morning
what a stupid son of a [__]
this is oh Joe yeah disaster is the only
word for it is awful
it's awful
you gotta love that the unions just what
was it like a month ago Dan how long ago
was it yeah it was like November so
they're like we need better safety
conditions yeah and Joe Biden's back get
back on that train
of vinyl chloride
just make sure it's balanced like
what a disaster look at every [__]
car of that [__]
how does a train derail that bad like in
this day and age
uh uh you don't load it correctly
apparently uh that's right I guess they
said um
like 40 percent of the weight was on the
back third of this train car and um not
that I'm an expert on these things but
from what I was reading that apparently
is very dangerous because they need to
slow down at all the back cars are so
heavy they slam into the ones in front
of them in a jacket what the [__] that
seems like a so obvious thing to avoid
yeah but there it's all about time it's
like we don't have time to rearrange
these cars just get them on there get
them going it'll be fine until it's not
and then this happens that's disgusting
I'm saying they were understaffed too I
probably had a big we can't afford them
Union folk running me about 25 an hour I
get me I got me some of the
some of them
undocumented workers do this kind of
work here for me for five dollars
under the table it's good pay
them up outside Home Depot and I said
just make sure it's balanced like
they good at balancing yeah they asked
me who is this character
I don't know the sheriff he's he's
in Ohio yeah he controls a lot
it's more like Greg Paul in Ohio there's
someone who's still Ohio every every
summer don't be challenging my accent
now Dan I'll find you placed on a train
now I'm a [__] Savage
GPS up
yes right
you ever smell Vinyl chloride in the
morning there Diane
something up and wake you up faster than
that boy
oh my God
the crew was alerted by an alarm shortly
before the derailment indicating a
mechanical issue
an emergency brake was pulled but 10
trains still derailed and evacuation
order is put in place in the general
area one day after the incident advising
people to relocate to be on two mile
radius
now my needs all y'all we had a slot
accident over here now gonna need y'all
to take a step back and if you can avoid
breathing for the time being
can you go back oh dude that's crazy
when you pulled it's like this Louisiana
Plantation owner that for some reason is
this is the sheriff of now listen here I
tell you I've seen this before nothing
to worry about
just take a few steps back
now if you live in a two mile radius
you're going to go ahead and just set up
camp two miles from here
I don't have another house well that
well you can stay in your house
just don't breathe
um
that's right just close your windows now
it ain't no big problem
breathing high levels of vinyl chloride
can make someone pass out or die oh
corpse husband no don't Breathe
No courts you know what he's so emo he
does it because he knows it's like I
don't care if I have he's self-l orgasm
in my lungs this is inappropriate
this is just not cool yeah it's a little
off the rails here right it's just not
cool to conjure up such a beautiful uh
Zach why haven't you played it yet
obviously because I we've already played
it it's back
so perfect why wouldn't you play it I
pulled up the picture I don't know
you've been laughing so much she's
played yeah just play it go for it
who's gonna get mad at us for this who's
gonna get mad at us or the whole state
of Ohio I will who cares I will
I [__] love Cedar it is kind of it is
kind of interesting the levels of
severity that people make fun of you I
think I think the difference with cutie
is that like this is a direct person who
I know who's watching it all them over
here in India Ohio dine of suffocating
all that kind of business Ain't No
Rotten this show but play the damn song
Zach
oh cooking chestnuts over vinyl chloride
that's why I did it [__]
don't you eat those chestnuts or you'll
get cancer
[Music]
why'd you pull up the same photo
I didn't say that you had already shown
it oh yeah
yeah so where were we um
breathing in high levels of vinyl
chloride can make someone pass out or
die if they don't get fresh air and has
been linked to an increased risk of
cancer and deliver brain lungs and blood
yeah just cancer the liver brain loves
and blood
that doesn't that sounds survivable
I mean there's at least a thousand
different kind of cancers out there
that's only four of your organs liver
brain lungs and blood ain't no problem
with that chances are still pretty good
you'll be fine
just take a couple steps back that's all
now I hope you get ass cancer and die
you son of a [__] I'll cut your throat
I'll come to your house and kill your
children I got there chill this will
have been through enough you animal stop
uh why specify even specify where you
get it yes all your major it's not good
just your body just your liver your
brain your lungs and your blood
ugly you're disgusting I'm gonna kill
you Dr Phil chill the [__] out what what
is he on today
officials warned the controlled burn
would send a phos gene and hydrogen
chloride into the air phosgene is a
highly toxic colorless gas with a strong
odor that can cause vomiting and
breathing trouble and was used as a
weapon in World War One
why is that making you up it's so insane
it's [__] insane yeah no it's this is
nuts like like the incompetency the
negligence it's [__]
it's so disgusting it's gross it's gross
and I'll tell you I think uh the whole
[__]
you get two conspiratorial on you but
the whole uh obsession with UFOs the
last week I I there's no such thing as a
coincidence that's all I'm saying
interesting
so look look at this look at the jingly
shiny over here
don't pay attention
[Music]
listen to this
they say
phos Gene is considered safe at point
one parts per million
during an eight-hour exposure or 0.2
parts per million for a 15 minute
exposure
so I wonder what parts per they're like
what how many parts per million is it
500 000 1.3 million dollars it's about
yeah but when it's just a giant pool of
it and a ditch on fire I feel like
you're gonna hit that uh parts per
million hey Sheriff
that says it's got to be
1.1 part per million what are we at now
oh let me check here now oh about
about 750 000 per million
no problem
hey uh
I'll tell you we've been trying to cut
down on crime
now we got this fox Gene toxic gas going
through the streams ain't nobody
committing no crime right now but I tell
you
like World War one man I remember that
was yesterday you just dug up a video of
a guy talking about
um all that stuff with the uh
it's called the Precision scheduled
railroad which is the system that uh the
rail workers were training workers get
rid of and uh failed too an Ohio Watcher
sent this in thank you Sierra oh thank
you everyone who knows [__] about this I
love you thank you for sharing
we got to bring this story to the world
dude because nobody's talking about it
and H3 podcast is
yeah I mean it's not like that's a total
blackout obviously like if you look
there's plenty of news and I'm sure it's
I'm sure it's the lead story in Ohio
um I I have to imagine but as far as um
you know what's dominating the headlines
on all the networks and everything for
the past week uh very little talk of
this a lot of talk about uh
UFOs and weather balloons and stuff
[Music]
tell you what have we ruled out
that it was a weather balloon that
derailed this here train good question
now I'm no conspiracy dearest but I do
believe that
Obama was an alien
but I will say this
[Music]
we gotta have them ribs and [__] too
what the [__] dude nobody does sound
bites like us nobody nobody who the [__]
got Obama saying gotta have them ribs
and [__] too
all right let's watch this [__] rant
workers warned us about disaster like
this I heard firsthand months ago about
the corporate practice of precision
scheduled railroading Precision
scheduled railroading is uh shorter
staff longer hours seven weeks longer
trains less safety less maintenance do I
have all that right oh you got it all
right I mean there you go we save
ourselves ten thousand dollars a month
now
the federal government going to spend
about 10 trillion dollars but ain't come
out of my pocket boy
mm-hmm
save me's a little bit of cheddar
that's right
how much money it costs to clean up an
ecological disaster on this oh about 10
trillion dollars
it's a good payoff the drill message
you're seeing on national TV this person
said
I'm in Columbus Ohio nobody's talking
about it are you serious
yeah
so weird
pretty there's one of a few things just
like maintenance on the track where
they've cut the track games too short
and they can't get out to fix it or
they've cut the carbons which is the
union that works on the rail cars so we
have one deroma here in Northeast Ohio
where will flange was very thin and it
picked a switch and derailed the entire
train luckily it was full of candle wax
and not something highly volatile rail
workers tried to strike over this stuff
but were stopped by Congress a few weeks
later and here we are several Norfolk
Southern cars of toxic highly volatile
chemicals exploded fantastically in the
Tiny Town of East Palestine Ohio 20
miles from where I grew up so I met
Clyde in East Palestine to ask him about
it it looks like a faulty bearing
because the catastrophic derailment
these railroads are turning profits and
over fist they cut their Workforce to
Bare Bones and now they're playing the
process for it because
wheels are falling off the train
basically Carmen were inspecting cars
about three minutes per car that's
always been the industry standard now
it's 90 seconds per car is that because
of PSR yes it's a roast job right now
and these guys are under pressure I mean
they're working men and women and you
know they don't hurry up and get this
car done they're going to be fired great
points so I went to a press conference
with Norfolk Southern and Ohio Governor
Mike dewine to ask them about this what
could Precision scheduled railroad have
to do with the axle failure that caused
the derailment who is this guy he rocks
like he's like actually going in like yo
this guy's journalism more perfect union
is his Tick Tock okay shout out this guy
this guy here is in charge of the
derailment this why does he look exactly
like I thought he would
this man here you know what this man
here breathed a little too much vinyl
chloride
fully coherent very smart fella
went down to the train came back looking
like this
looks like he got Sling Blade some
people called banana blade I call it
Sling Blade he got what would you say
you know Sling Blade
Oh yeah talk of my language now
I tell you what man you ever put some
Vinyl chloride over a a a uh steamed
potato oh boy french fried potatoes
I'll tell you what man might give me
cancer but boy that tastes good
um
that's right oh yeah maybe I'm waiting
for it to start raining in chloride
vinyl then
I'm just going to come out put my lip my
tongue out man tastes like sugar
we said uh more perfect union was
created by former Bernie people uh
Bernie 2020 people it's a really great
source for labor news okay cool I'll uh
give them a follow because the fact he
actually went there and directly asked
the uh the Norfolk people this is
actually the best recording I've seen on
the topic genuinely
oh reporters were being arrested
reporting on it is that there was a
story of one person uh a reporter being
arrested for uh
it just sounds okay thank you it sounded
like cops just being being caught hey
now they're like who decided to set this
fire hey you better come back here now
you under arrest
was it you hey come on man
I'm the sheriff around these parts that
ain't my cult
you're under arrest
I have no idea that's a mechanical issue
we're out the podium is the governor of
Ohio by the way
oh really yeah don't ever say looks
don't factor in
to a at least I think somebody in the
chat said that this is the same guy
right
oh he looks more normal there it's him
tell by the glasses it looks like he
just pulled him off the street and put a
suit on him for Christ's sake he's a
he's a body double
body it was Saddam style Body Double
yeah well he's like hell no ain't no
going breed that God damn chlorines
[__] imma send the body double
the wine to ask them about this what
could Precision scheduled railroad have
to do with the axle failure that caused
the derailment
I have no idea that it's a mechanical
issue we're out for precision scheduled
railroading is a management
process not a great answer and that's
probably because Norfolk Southern let a
worker take the fall rather than a
single corporate executive showing up in
the town that they polluted to be held
accountable you see Wall Street owns
Norfolk Southern 74 percent of shares
are owned by a who's who of Infamous
hedge funds and this is the business
model that they demand profit at any
cost and disaster like this is simply a
cost of doing business they cut
everything make all the money and pay
off disasters and Tiny flyover towns
from The Profit but instead of answering
for any of that they're betting that the
corporate media under the same pressure
for extreme profit as railroads will
only ask questions about how much cancer
people will get and not why this
preventable disaster happened
[Music]
so [__] gross
so gross dude
uh it's gross
hydrogen chloride is a colorless
yellowless gas with a strong odor it'll
make your eyes
uh human effect on skin eye and noses
irritation and throat
that's a different one I guess
yeah when it burns uh this chemical it
releases like a a bunch of different
gases and stuff so
um let's see professor of chemistry
at Carnegie University said this vinyl
chloride is bad
[Applause]
there is a comma and I've always said
that
says vinyl chloride is bad dioxins are
worse as carcinogens and that comes from
burning I love that
well the worst thing about the worst
thing you could do is set it on fire
let's set it on fire
wrap it up
dioxin is a group of persistent
environmental pollutants that lasts in
the ground and body for years and have
been one of the major environmental
problems and controversies in the United
States
roughly 5 000 residents were forced to
evacuate
farmers and animal owners have reported
their animals are falling ill very
quickly out of nowhere he just started
coughing really hard just shut down and
he had liquid diarrhea and just went
very fast
that's encouraging that's very
terrifying that was a man talking about
his faucets
foxes it's foxes no it's Fox said
people domesticate foxes I'm just
unlimited into amounts probably a skin
farmer
or
maybe no maybe maybe that
what you talk about Fox that was my wife
that's less cute
talking about my wife for God's sake she
had liquid diarrhea and died right there
it's not funny
no it's just the way it's reported you
assume it's a fox but what if he's
talking about like
his wife there's [__] all over the floor
oh no don't show me this is this the fox
that died oh we're not come on what are
we what are we doing here I don't know
if he died this is him talking about one
of his six foxes though
let's see it let's see the difference
Taylor Holzer he said his foxes have
been falling ill since the derailment
dude [__] we got to get everybody out of
there man yeah I said he he's probably
definitely not a farmer I was making all
right he's just not a farmer yeah
probably not
generally Farmers stay away from foxes I
thought yo we got to get what do we do
how can we help these people Chicago
reports of dead animals well outside the
original evacuation Zone continue to
stoke fear
the rail Workers Union was just in a
contract battle we talked about that
so there's that
um
nightmare eh
it's a nightmare
and I yeah what do we do about it no
[__] clue it's like nationalize the
railroads they they
cut everything and then when something
happens people donate and help and [__]
and they just like Skate On by yeah the
thing is is like this is this is so far
beyond like oh let's let's donate and
fundraise because this is
they probably poison that whole area for
the next like 150 years you know what I
mean like this is
not a uh a quick thing
but those people need to get the [__]
out of there I mean
yeah I mean I don't
some people can't I don't know if
there's even what is the problem it's
like what are you I don't even know if
there is a place for us to donate to or
if anything's even been set up at this
point
speaking of you know this whole
bureaucratic uh I don't know if this is
bureaucratic but listen to this
I was listening to a story this morning
so the Navy wasted they wanted to make
this ship do you know about this it's
supposed to be the most literal yeah
yeah I do know about that the littoral
battleship it was meant to be the most
Cutting Edge
they built it to fight terrorists they
started building it after 9 11.
terrorist boats and they just started
launching them and it turns out they're
[__] so so so bad they leak the gears
break the engine shuts down these things
cost
500 million dollars a piece oh yeah that
seems low and they made
yeah they they said it was a quote
unquote deal
it's a steal so they each one of these
costs 500 million
and there's and there's a they made like
you know 15 of them or something and so
the Navy was like
listen
I we know we we've wasted all this money
on this [__] but I think it's time to
cut our losses
we're gonna cut our [__] losses these
ships are not even they're already uh
obsolete
and we have no use for them
so they've wasted like 10 billion
dollars on this program
and then in Florida there was this um
Shipyard that had a billion dollar
contract to maintain these ships and
when the Navy said we're gonna cancel
the program
the shipyard lobbied Congress
and convinced enough Republican
congressmen
to block the Navy from canceling it so
they could keep repairing them
do you understand how [__] insane
this is
the Navy's like we don't want to use
these anymore they don't work
yeah and then the and then Congress is
like well no you gotta keep them in
service so that we can pay the people to
repair it
what the [__] are you what are we
talking about it doesn't work
of course you're gonna need to repair it
we create lots of jobs though probably
not that many
[Music]
it it's insane it's insane this is a lot
of [__] money
that's all of our tax money
we gotta repair them mine
the Navy the Navy was like literally
these ships are hurting our Navy who
wants me to take their money because
they're just sapping resources tapping
resources they'd be utterly useless in
Modern Warfare
right who wants to lose some money no
sir that'd be a great waste that's what
the Congress guy said you could find out
his name he's some [__] piece of [__]
from Florida Republican Congressman
commits enough Republicans
we need the ships
who's going to repair them
if we'd come decommission them who's
going to repair them
it ain't right
that's right we gotta
if we ain't repairing the five billion
dollar ship
then
what's the point of even building the
ship to begin with I built the ship so
that we could repair it
if we ain't repairing the ship what's
the point of making them
that's a good question
now this year costed a mere 10 billion
dollars
[Music]
this whole city
in Florida depend on us repairing them
ships
[Music]
you understand what I'm trying to say
now it ain't about to go into battle
that thing don't barely goddamn float
which is why it needs so many repairs
mm-hmm
in fact I think y'all should keep
launching them so we got more to repair
that's right
um
it's so [__] incompetent and
nonsensical at every [__] level
my resolution
airstrikes yeah let's just blow it up
man these people's lives aren't so
Disturbed for absolutely no reason like
this didn't have to happen at all well
then so my point I guess that connects
it is like
a billion dollars wasting on repairing
boats that the Navy doesn't want
and that already that don't [__]
float already literally could could save
all these people right now
maybe God damn Maybe
if we could just get some of them boats
to repair down to Palestine
we could bring all kinds of money into
that their City
y'all know how to repair a boat
that don't matter the thing don't work
anyway just hit it with a ranch call it
a day
mm-hmm
that's right that's what I do show up at
work
uh dude our country is insanely [__]
stupid dude it's so stupid it's
disgusting it makes me want to [__]
vomit
I feel like I'm breathing Vinyl chloride
right now I want to vomit so much this
is America This Is Our Land
I don't understand why palestine's so
poor don't they got no boats to repair
president Trump if you see this please
save us Congress is handing out money to
repair boats you ain't got no boats to
repair boy
okay that's the American flag anymore
I could truck one into you oh you're
landlocked let me truck one in you could
start repairing
love that
all right let's thank our sponsor and
then
we can move on from this
but we'll follow it I'm gonna follow
this story
yeah I'm sure we'll talk about it on
Thursday
thank you to Honey man
[Music]
which
tastes great with or without
tastes great on pizza
fluoride
what is it vinyl flooring tie any of
that into the ad please well yeah right
the hard Segway it's hard Segway but
we're gonna have to
find a smoother one I think but we do
love honey honey is amazing and today
there are our sponsors so thank you to
them you know you can save with honey
now on your iPhone or computer
how awesome is that you know
I just remembered and unfortunately I
[__] lost the screenshot I don't know
what happened to it but I just got one
this past weekend or last week
uh buying Valentine's stuff for Ally oh
yeah and it popped up saved me like 30
bucks what were you buy or I mean
flowers and just flowers and stuff and
some some sweets that's nice good man
wait wait me Ela had a huge one too did
she send you that one uh is in here she
bought what did she buy
Ela had a bat one yeah let me find it
over the weekend and here here's what
honey is it's a plug-in
when you're on your phone or browsing
there it is
this one at the top
Canada
I don't know why it must be a Canadian
company what are you saving Canadian
dollars 150 Canadian dollars
here's how it works it's a plug-in it's
so easy to install it's literally like
two clicks boom
and it's free to use and what it does is
it scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart automatically
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites
and when you're getting ready to check
out a honey button appears all you got
to do is click it apply coupons it says
click that wait a few seconds honey
searches for the best coupons you can
find for that website and automatically
applies them
you watch the price drop magically and
it is revolutionary it really is
Join the Revolution I I would say like
maybe 75 of the stuff I buy on the
internet
has a honey coat that I would have never
found otherwise you don't even have to
think about it dude and true
it's nuts man
you can say I mean they have it on
clothes Tech food
pretty much everything this one Ela I
think what she bought a table or
something
you know
also big news it doesn't just work on
the desktops now it works on your iPhone
too just activated on Safari on your
phone and save on the go so if you don't
already have honey you are going to be
straight up missing out on huge money in
your pocket and by getting it not only
will you be doing yourself a solid
you'll be helping to support us
and the show that you love
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com h3tv that's joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you to honey we love you
honey
yes
let's go okay throw it up in the air
honey man if only there was honey in
those [__] trains in the final four
eyes so true then it would be a
delightful afternoon I'd be out there
with a spoon yeah am I right
got some oatmeal and just gather it up
and trick you know trickle it on there
here's some more photos just because I I
wanted to see more from my own personal
interest
let's see
Gizmo with the with the facts
now we out here asking questions about
you ain't seen the sheriff said nothing
on fire right
you know what to say when the FBI asked
who lit this on fire
oh [__] that looks gnarly
it's in the water I love that
jeez dude
that's what it looks like when they set
it on fire
[__] that
of course the poor people always get
screwed so I'm sure is like a not a
wealthy place you know some small town
in Ohio
these people cannot afford to relocate
uh I yeah I'm not familiar with that
town but
imagine you're probably you never heard
of East Palestine I have not
cheers
damn it man this is no time for
trampoline
[Music]
there's a toxic spill didn't you here
what y'all squatting about man
[Music]
I guess that's it yeah pretty
interesting and a horrific kind of uh
way so
let's keep it let's keep it going let's
keep the energy going for it
yeah um
Nick Clark says you know they've already
written an HBO movie about it right
the script writers are first on the
scene actually before even the they
already wrote a EPA is there they
already made a movie about exactly this
that movie White Noise last year was a
Netflix movie it was about a train
derailment ecological oh really sure was
it yeah and as a matter of fact uh it
was based off of um
it was based off an incident that
happened I think in the 80s or something
very good could be wrong on that but
anyways the um the residents of this
town coincidentally were used as extras
in the disaster scenes in that movie
so they they acted in a movie where
basically this happened uh just a year
or two ago they used the people who were
victims of the ecological disaster to be
extras the other way around this
happened before
I'm saying they use people in this town
in Ohio
as extras in a movie about a train
deranged it is very weird
so some of these people are like that
is a crazy coincidence I just did a
movie about a trained disaster that's
exactly right my life is a movie
welcome everybody to Palestine I just
like the one in the Middle East it's on
fire
Palestine Ohio baby palm Palestine Ohio
that's crazy Amy that you just said that
I said long lady I don't think he said I
think you somehow managed to I said Long
Live Palestine Ohio
[Laughter]
[Music]
Palestine Ohio no don't don't do that no
and love let's uh let's move on from the
story so much love to Palestine Ohio so
much love to Palestine Ohio
boy all right let's move on so yeah we
were giving Gabe some [__]
um
Elaine Christian thank you for the
gifted we were giving Gabe some [__] for
not showing up to elenities party Emery
alinity was there though in your defense
sorry amaranth uh and and it turns out
that well
I guess we got some receipts from Nick
this comes compliments of yuge uh Zach
yes
so let's see for the record I gave Gabe
the invite he doesn't remember names and
we couldn't make it that night
he's very for the [__] Gabe is
forgetful he said Okay Okay so
so he's forgetful all right so he's
absolved
yeah turn to let him off that easy I
forgot too I forgot about his birthday
party I had a lot going on yeah
you're not that forget fully members to
call in every Friday everybody seems to
think you're gonna get a strike for what
you just said uh no it's flat no
everybody everybody relax it wasn't that
big a deal air strikes
was obviously a goof not that serious at
all
[Music]
trust me I have a sense of these things
after working with Ethan for a few years
yeah I do too yeah no just a goofball I
just misheard Maybe
it's my fault well my family
Long Live Palestine Ohio
it's not your fault
the joke of course is that you don't
support the other Palestine Maybe
I do long-living the other Palestine as
well putting on the hot seat there a
little bit swinging it back at you
I support Palestine as well both in Ohio
and the middle easy
and the good news is we've we're getting
that kill switch soon too right another
yeah uh yeah it is uh it is in the works
um theoretically we'll have it in a few
weeks here so uh
it's twenty thousand dollars that's how
smooth that is I didn't wanna
yeah it's expensive and it's going to
pay for itself in like a week probably
okay
yeah how why because it's high-end
professional uh broadcast video gear and
it's expensive I I said from the
beginning it was going to be expensive
it was actually I still underestimated I
thought it was going to be like seven or
eight grand but it ended up being quite
a bit more than that well the technology
is pretty interesting right I mean uh
it's really good I mean this is the
device that's used on uh they were
probably using it on the Super Bowl last
night right wow so that's a good deal if
you're talking about the Super Bowl but
for us that's a lot of money yes indeed
but I mean if it prevents one strike it
will have paid for itself oh yeah my
attitude oh yeah
it prevents one
sponsor right exactly for itself
yeah the chapter 20 20K well spent
somebody said oh yeah yeah at this point
I mean I'll be honest with you guys
I'll be totally honest with you guys at
this point with all the dumb [__] I've
said I've definitely lost millions of
dollars and I'm not exaggerating
yeah I'm I'm not exaggerating when I
tell you I've lost Millions several
Millions not even just one
is no
what the [__]
millions of Jews so 20K is pretty good
you think that I'd be more
bothered by it but
I kind of just get a couple
well I mean you're once you're well off
enough what what's what's a couple
million right
between you and I that's a lot of money
no I know
somebody said that's why you're the
greatest that's right he does laying it
all in the line that's why I'm the
greatest that's what I was getting best
ever do it I'm the best that ever did it
that's right
this is why you're watching you're of
course referring to over the course of
like the run of the podcast like the
amount of
canceled sponsors that have happened
yeah getting banned and yeah yeah yeah
yeah and sponsors
yeah but it's okay you know what I mean
well the kill switch is going to be a
fun element I feel like it's going to be
something fun to play with anyway yeah
people have been asking me if I'm
worried that it's gonna wind up getting
me in trouble with you if I use it in
something in an instance where well
you're like oh that would have been fine
yeah it might piss me off but I feel
like that will be interesting content
also like the conflict that will be good
okay that's that's true I feel only good
things coming out of this yeah
yeah Dan you got to be on your a game
man Even's gonna be much more loose lip
now no that worries me too you're gonna
lean on it I'm not gonna do that okay
but we what are we gonna set it to like
30 seconds uh the model that we're
getting uh can do it's variable
um and yeah you can do I believe that
one goes up to a minute and a half
anywhere from 30 seconds to a minute and
a half I don't really have too much
delay no I agree because it the longer
the delay the harder it is to interact
with chat and everything so I think 30
seconds is good it's gonna be funny
we'll be like okay do we hit the button
30 seconds
yeah
would yeah that'll be interesting to see
what Dan hits the button on
what will Schatzi when it's black or
when it's like crossed over just like
you can determine uh it can either you
know our hear this
we can have it cut to that
um retroactively you can also just have
it um I believe just dump the footage
because the thing is you're on a delay
and so if you remove 10 seconds right
it'll just skip ahead so from the
viewer's perspective they'll just be a
sudden jump cut too
we should do the technical difficulty
thing one is funny and two it allows us
to use the button again
right right big massive massive because
if you cut forward
then you lose your lead uh yeah well
that's so here's what the twenty
thousand dollars gets you is this device
is actually smart enough that once you
do that it has a makeup mode where it
will then start playing back the rest of
the podcast
um ever so slightly sped up like a 105
speed or something yeah so it's not
really perceptible but then it will gain
back that loss dude this thing's insane
like I said I mean this is a this is a
this is the real deal this is like
what's used in control rooms for Network
TV and stuff is this your dream to be
you get work with all the highest Tech
[__] bro I mean I would love to
so who's going to have the kill switch
just you and I love you too okay that's
fun that's fun you'll have one on your
desk and then I'll have uh uh it's just
gonna be like a big red button can we do
something like that it literally is that
I'll show you what it looks like it's
like kind of comical it looks can we get
a big red button shot for the kill
switch
you'll probably be able to see it next
to you if you just have it right next to
your laptop there so we're gonna have 30
seconds to kind of convene real fast
it's like the nuclear codes uh yeah well
what do we do we can pre-record
something that shows us hitting the
button so when you hit it that's what oh
that's what plays yeah this is slam down
that's a really good idea maybe yes this
is uh what it looks like so what's the
two different buttons one is audio and
one is video
oh so audio is actually you can just you
can have it just dip out audio as well
although people would still Could Read
My Lips which might be a problem
[Music]
plausible deniability well I mean it's
it's totally yeah the audio drops out
because I hit the Doom button right that
pretty much well that's it it's
interesting it also has this fancy thing
where instead it you can set it to
either do a beep like a sensor beep or
to just drop out the audio altogether or
it has this fancy thing where it will
scramble your voice
um with some sort of audio processing so
it sounds like you're speaking some made
up that's an alien language but it's
still your voice like I don't like that
because I feel like if I was watching
that I would think I was like having an
aneurysm I'm not going I mean dude right
you already do that
okay this is exciting actually [__] I'm
I'm pretty I'm pretty hyped for this
yeah all my haters are crying at home
right now I feel like all massive
streamers should have one of those I was
talking about this the other day and
maybe I shouldn't say this publicly but
the fact that this is something that
does this function
there there are really primitive ways to
do it like I could do something similar
than this uh to this without spending
this much uh money but it would be way
clunkier and less reliable
um and obviously you need this to be
reliable otherwise what's the point
um but yeah with the amount of times
that uh streamers you know yourself
included make soon hop off and make uh
oopsie doopy I feel like there is a uh
Market segment you want to invest
entrepreneuring uh well if you could
make one that's more of like a prosumer
version that only costs like a grand
instead of 20. no you could sell it to
Shark Tank streamers
love this I do feel like it would
probably be very expensive and take a
long time to actually make that product
yeah I'm not the person to do it but is
somebody smarter than me
um
but give me a call
I'd love to invest but I just lost
millions of dollars uh to respond I got
it it's kind of a vicious cycle time to
invest
no I I agree with you Dan it's uh it's a
great product and I'm very excited to
have it
people said the thing is uh the chat
delay might kill enter activity yeah I
mean that's the trade-off right like it
is nice to be able to
have a real time back and forth with
your audience and that's definitely one
of the big appeals for streaming but uh
you gotta weigh that versus
um losing your livelihood I don't think
anyone else really has this problem on
the level that we do
twenty thousand dollars a lot of [__]
money nobody else has an Ethan Nobody
Does it Like Ethan maybe everybody does
it
you ever smelled that it's Ripple people
don't even know what we're talking about
yeah Dan Dan and Ian congratulations on
the new meme you guys launched over the
weekend speaking of the Super Bowl thank
you thank you you guys absolutely nailed
this uh
what is this meme called toy Jack soy
Jack
yeah you guys were stoked to see Mr
Beast huh Mr B he came on the screen and
Ian and I immediately snapped our heads
at each other and went
oh Mr Beast dude you guys nailed it
that's so good it took a second to get
that screenshot of Mr Beast yeah
rewinding it and pausing it on the
because he was literally on screen in
this commercial for about a second and a
half wait what was the commercial for
God I don't even remember what was it
he was just randomly it was just like it
was a cameo it like wasn't his
commercial he just like showed up in it
is anybody in the chat remember what
that commercial was for wasn't very good
marketing no clearly not we don't we
have no idea I mean I'm assuming phone
because he's holding a phone and that's
the only thing visible like a product he
said he missed it that he missed
something I didn't understand Mr Beast
missed it like he well that's what he
said in that shot
oh he was trying to take out his phone
right right it's uh it seems it's an NFL
commercial oh it wasn't anything run
with the commercial you're we're already
watching the Super Bowl it's for women
to highlight women in football okay hit
the switch is an ally I was about to say
the number one advocate for women in
football Mr Beast that's right folks we
love female actors
some people are asking if it's
intentional I love the idea of this not
being intentional you guys are just
stuck yeah yeah our face we just wound
up like that
so funny you guys just posted this it's
Mr Bistro
oh [__] that's so good you guys need to
send that to the NFL they're like ad
campaign's working perfect this is what
we wanted
actually you guys uh I really have to
pee oh this son of a [__] people really
been going hard on this meme though the
avatar
[Music]
this you guys in the film I'm not even
kidding you guys are we were doing that
in the theater right Ian like him and I
jumped up when the toonkun came on
screen that's right we're like bro no
way
um
also I want to give a shout out to our
soon-to-be president
who Rihanna was the the halftime act and
of course uh Trump did not like it for
some reason dude I was dying when I saw
it
Trump said epic fail Rihanna gave
without question the single worst
halftime show in Super Bowl history
this after insulting so far more than
half of our nation
which is already in serious decline with
her foul and insulting language also so
much for her stylist no no no no hey
he's such a queen
it is very sassy
these are he could have he could have
hit it with one of these
you know yeah man I'll just leave it at
that I had a beat off
people say that every year though uh
this was the worst one ever I didn't
watch it did you guys like it or I mean
I watched it but I was too I watched it
I thought it was pretty awesome I was
she has a lot of Bops yeah that was what
everybody was commenting on the whole
time it was going on because as she did
the medley of all of her hits yeah I
just forgot she's got it's alive yeah
she's got a lot of hits jams
it was horrible
what is he saying she insulted half the
nation with her foul language
is he just talking about the lyrics I
guess so the lyrics are so disturbing
folks yeah
she's talking about sex it's terrible
you were dressing up in lingerie before
your mirror at home tucking your dick
between your legs imagine you have a
vagina for sexual kick there's nothing
sexual about that yes right Jordan
she also announced or teased that she
was pregnant during the performance like
right at the beginning it seemed out and
she like touched her stomach like she
was pregnant and some people are like
she gave like a boring performance she
literally is pregnant and she
hosted the Super Bowl halftime show like
she did she did the dancing was
interesting too it was almost like they
did all the dancing routines around her
being pregnant like staccato moving yeah
very little I loved it yeah oh there was
nothing sexual about that
uh yeah it was I didn't find it very
sexy but I don't really care that much
really
is it the same uh that baby daddy
yeah
that's nice nice family they're building
Rihanna's baby in the womb right now
he's always killing me bro I don't know
why so stupid but I love it
[Music]
[Laughter]
inspired by Super Smash Bros apparently
uh her performance
yeah we'd like oh that's that is we
immediately like made that observation
and then we were far from the only ones
to notice that because it's kind of
edits well when have you ever seen
platforms floating like that yeah
exactly so cool
somebody made a made a video edit here
let's take a look
oh I have a feeling we're gonna get
claimed for this policy
oh
That's good I've been afraid to watch
too much but I like it
also shout out to Elon Musk who was
there enjoying the Super Bowl as we know
Elon Musk is a man of the people he is a
freedom of speech Warrior yes and yes or
is why he's besties with the one and
only free speech Warrior and man of the
people Rupert Murdoch yep
don't believe the mainstream media's
lies I guess Elon isn't for free speech
after all
what how was that Ninja
that was a dude that said identity uh
oh he said I was doing identity theft
right why did he say that
uh because you were oh I changed my name
to yeah yeah awesome idiot stupid
[__] idiot
yes so here's your man
's in that photo Rupert Murdoch
Elizabeth
okay hot dog Queen get that Glizzy
Glizzy is
[Applause]
[Music]
love me
pays our checks too so that's always
good
but
damn she's been going for ruperts like
what she ate her Glizzy and then she
grabbed his Glizzy but uh yeah but she'd
take from him
okay and then she goes for his I feel
like it's a nap
come on come on this is some good NFL
play-by-player yeah it is let's take a
look we're gonna have to review this
play put the yellow team John Madden
level analysis and do you know who this
woman is and she some also also some
like super I believe uh that is the CEO
of Fox News oh we love that for her what
a great character good people all around
Dan Scott what is it like isn't it
awesome being rich
like what did they talk about oh
our employers our employee
oh yes past the mustard please
do you have any gray Poupon for my
Glizzy
all of my employees are such suckers
oh my God how do you do Mr Murdock
I was exploiting your workers this year
Ben very good I made 50 billion dollars
yes yes I hope your todger is doing well
while sucking a smoker
we're stuck in some smokers in there
watching Arena here's your man of the
people what a [__] clown show
goddamn
told you weiner Lena
I'm dreaming of my next Tucker wait he
erased this why because they lost what
Elon stupid no Eagles
and then never mind they lost then he
erased it
[Music]
is he embarrassed he's like she cringe I
picked wrong damn it it's like what
connection does he have to the Eagles
the Eagles got ratio dude
delete why would you erase it be proud
the hypothesis was false he just said go
Eagles well he should have deleted it
his hypothesis was false and as a true
scientist I think that he didn't even
make a hype he made a retraction he just
said go Eagles
so funny what a loser so insecure little
[__] baby also the decorations with
the three flags on either side really he
really yeah well not the eagle Emoji
what is this Emoji game he sucks do you
think the American flag is in his like
most recently used like he does it a lot
probably I think it's on the home page I
bet yeah it's a good way for him to
pretend that he cares about America
there's a goddamn eagle Emoji man all
right I'm gonna go pee and then we have
a secret video dedicated to Dan oh no I
had a feeling because I asked what that
meant and he was a lot with his response
you know what it is though no I have no
idea we have a top secret video that's
been in the works it's been in the works
for Dan oh no are you guys gonna
embarrass me you should be what Jesus
that was loud you should be scared and
and on the edge of your seat but I'm
gonna go to the bathroom and then we'll
watch it you could just stew in that in
that Terror yeah Dan asked me what it
was and I said it's a secret bro that's
why it's labeled secret I don't even
worry about it
Joy hands here who knows who's no who
knows who's in on this yeah uh Zach Zach
um I told you Ian not me I have no idea
what you guys are talking about either
yeah first of all look at Lena's hair
can we talk about it thank you Olivia
yeah Lena cut her hair she got
highlights
I'm so happy it looks so pretty yes and
can we talk about Olivia's makeup too
yes Chad was saying we need to see that
that's makeup
you know it looks great Zachary Lewis
The Rock looks awesome also oh thank you
I mean Lena went to the same stylist
after I uh destroyed my hair last time
it was like please just go to my stylist
and I was like all right I'll stop doing
it myself and it turned out good so
shout out Jess
[Music]
um do we want to talk about how I was
magic yesterday with my guesses
go for it yesterday we were putting bets
on like who we think we're gonna see in
commercials I hit two like super neat
like back to back I felt like those were
great guesses that I pulled
and they were back to back is the thing
it went kiss and then Martha Stewart
and I felt magic in that moment
it was it was impressive thank you all
done
I took a lap around the room both times
someone sent me you did actually I
remember noting that Zachary Lewis I
don't know if we should Roxy oh yeah
exactly
someone sent me a really good xqc video
I don't know if we should wait for Ethan
for it it's 30 seconds I thought it was
funny I don't know if everyone else will
find it find it that good but
I hear him coming out of the bathroom so
maybe we'll wait for him I'll just add
it to the doctor drop it in there yeah
a character
Shiro
character
what was that love
Shiro hero he's when he saw ashita he
once said shito oh yeah okay
she don't love did you watch the Super
Bowl was there playing in Sweden no no
Jesus no I didn't know Jesus geez
do you mean rugby I don't know what the
American Football is oh Jesus I mean
football
no
no that's not football it was a pretty
forgettable game
that's not football
wasn't anything like the Pat's greatest
comeback of all time the greatest
comeback in sports history not just
football history sports sports [__]
past history the because Tom Brady's the
goat man I love him
hello Papa's back
hello I just heard character a lot
yeah I've just someone just sent me
another xqc video that I can I open this
the title is a little provocative it is
but it's fine oh yeah I watched it okay
whatever bro whatever bro comes in here
says it says Charizard like he's like
you [__] special what
he said you're talking about Charizard
like he's not either special Charizard
that's that's
crazy that's crazy Charizard is basic as
[__] from first the first third
evolution
he's right that is controversial calling
Charizard basic as [__] for a third
evolution did he do that on purpose
unique or special I hear it that's crazy
that he managed to turn that into like a
devastating character
all right so I should go to the end
did you just say you
what oh my God
oh man
character
crazy huh
let's see
another classic xqc am I are we just
this is my favorite you see fans like I
I am I'm on board now I'm with love
welcome hi Stan
bam Cheeto
Cheeto
pretty high level stuff here you guys I
see what you like about him
there's more apparently everybody just
love them on she's the one Anisa was
talking about what
is jellyfish a herb what no
[Music]
wait what what even I don't even know
that come from
you because the turtle's eating it you
mean no he's just wondering if it's like
a vegetable because I'm confused but the
Herb's not like like a plantation
specifically an herb like a spice
foreign
[Music]
I think you're right Dan is that you he
hit the turtles eating it so he just
thinks that was nominal speculation
[Music]
because I know that turtles eat
jellyfish because when balloons
they look like jellyfish in the ocean
and that's why Turtles die and she's
just talking about they said their hair
what in the description on that video it
says that jellyfish are herbivores so
that's where he's getting that baby
okay but maybe that's what he thinks the
herbivore is they just eat herbs right I
know that's not always like it's not
totally random for him to be wondering
okay I think I think you're right Lena
with the uh
what is the herbivore that would make
sense though what's the herb or just an
animal that eats are you a dinosaur are
you asking for real are you you will
wonder yeah I've never heard that's just
an animal that eats plants
oh
opposite of a carnivore I this is why I
relate more with XTC than you guys I've
never heard about herbal door right but
what the [__]
what the [__] dude all right so
um anyway congratulations okay so secret
video time
all right Dan
I hope you're ready
it's a cameo it's a cameo get ready uh
oh you better
following your butthole together okay
special announcement from should I say
or does he say in the video
why not no will I not recognize
fetus you feel this energy between us
[Laughter]
I did
spread yeah you're looking good yeah
thank you
you gotta love in your life huh
you two got any spicy plans for
Valentine's Day huh I'm gonna smooch it
up a little bit
I'm gonna take her out to the Walmart
parking lot maybe slice open a hefty bag
of tuna fish lay it all out on the
asphalt and roll around in it huh
I bet you she'd love that
oh yeah
gosh stand damn damn damn where do I
begin you had the creamiest little scalp
uh-huh yeah a CLS as Kenneth would say
remember this
we used to slather that puppy and some
pickled mud fish and then unleash
Maurice and let him have his way
yeah Maurice remember Maurice
how the pussy's doing
good
still hairy still wrestling around yep
absolutely
right wish him the best for me huh five
oh wow
crazy what time does to people you know
that's right
okey-doke
I'm gonna get the hell out of here now
yeah so
you two
get weird
all right
cool
enjoy your Warhammer oh thank you
and uh
you know
stay away from the
the
pipes of the meat variety
because I
you know like either Meats
already
[__] out of here
that of course comes from your
girlfriend
[Music]
Ally to wish you a very fond so that was
from Al and Love Phil at Valentine's oh
how sweet what better to set the mood
than a love message from info Brent
I didn't put it together I thought you
guys put this together nope that was out
that was all her wow I'll have to
message her right now yeah
Happy Valentine's Day thank you thank
you and but and that tuna idea did that
did sound kind of into a good idea maybe
for you guys
rolling around some tuna in the wall
Walmart parking lot was that it yeah
okay
would you like me to report back
you can film it on how that film that
like
yeah though so there it is okay so let's
talk about
um
I guess let's get into The Joe Rogan
thing which starts with
oh we have so many why does it lie why
does it lie
Joe Rogan
had this insane take on Jewish people
that really [__] shocked me and it
kind of went under the radar I didn't
I didn't see anyone really caring about
it
um
here let me move some stuff around real
fast I am Jewish
here it wait not this
damn it
here it is
wrong browser
if we just have 30 seconds of dead air
do we hit the dead switch
possibly you know it's like ah that was
boring
maybe a bad joke that's exactly what I'm
worried about
dead air
anyway here's Joe Rogan check this out
tell me if you notice anything
odd about what he says here
sitting next to illian Omar where she's
she's apologizing for talking about it's
all about the Benjamins yeah which is
just about money she's talking about I
shouldn't have apologized some
anti-semitic statement I don't think
that is it's about Benjamins or money
you know the idea that Jewish people are
not into money is ridiculous listen it's
like saying Italians aren't into Pizza
it's [__] stupid listen it's [__]
stupid I understand that that is like so
overtly
shamelessly anti-Semitic
also a little [__] also a little
goofy of the comparison to the Italians
too hey Italians they love pizza they
all love pizza love about I love pizza
too I thought I loved pizza because it
was delicious
but it turns out well my kids are seven
percent Italian
uh but here's Joe Rogan
the way she phrased it like she could
have phrased it a different way so that
people would have less of a freak out
but can you not talk about the influence
of money in DC I mean this is very
obvious there's a very obvious reason
why for my entire life there's been a
uniparty consensus around our policy
vis-a-vis the Israeli government in a
total inability or unwillingness to
criticize the Israeli government it has
everything to do with organization and
yes money just like every other [__]
interest in DC and so yeah the fact that
she said that she got kicked off The
Foreign Affairs committee look I have
issues and disagreements with ilhan Omer
but she actually is one of the more
courageous voices on foreign policies I
don't know why they didn't cut it sooner
but obviously she's saying like you know
you can create this is a like a
common thing you hear and it's true you
can criticize Israel without being
anti-Semitic
but Joe Rogan's like yeah dude and also
like just saying that they're obsessed
with money is an anti-semitic at all
come on I could say anti-semitic things
and Adidas can't drop me but it's but
it's so not like saying Italians like
pizza
Italians weren't killed for [__]
eating pizza they weren't round up and
exterminated
also there isn't like a malicious
conspiracy that Italians
have a pizza gestapo that controls the
world I don't know it's so stupid
comparison this man can is so dumb he
could I don't know he's is he getting
Dumber he has no pizza experience I
think Alpha Brain might be toxic to the
brain
because this man gets Dumber
but yet nobody cares I guess when people
are anti-semitic I think it's all good
to to a point here
um
it's kind of crazy
sitting next to illian Omar where she's
she's apologizing for talking about it's
all about the Benjamins yeah which is
just about money she's talking about I
shouldn't have apologized it's not an
anti-semitic statement I don't think
that is it's about Benjamins are money
you know the idea that up to this point
we're not into money is ridiculous up to
that point when I saw this clip I was
like nodding along I'm like wait why are
people mad at Joe like he's making a
good point here or whatever and then it
just like takes this left turn and just
like come on that's like Italians and
pizza come on and money and Jews you
know that's the anti-semitic Trope
that's like literally why people hate
Jewish people
Joe Rogan you [__] idiot
Jews you love money look at your ass you
[__] you sold out to Spotify for like
hundreds of millions of dollars you love
money and if a Jewish person did that
then it'd all be about like oh greedy
Jew Joe Rogan loves money so [__]
much he's he shills scams
like Alpha Brain
or at least
I'm gonna call it a scam but like
it's dubious claims dubious is a good
word
I love the word dubious yeah that's a
great way did you learn it from
EverQuest of course I did yeah I was
just going through my head so awesome
that's so awesome Khan dubious that was
yellow right I believe it was yellow
you're not hostile but dubious
love that nobody knows what we're
talking nope like probably like 10
people in the audience yeah so
this whole thing about Jews love money
it's actually it's actually
the single worst
uh most damaging conspiratorial thing
about Jews Joe Rogan surrounded himself
with these um
white supremacists so much he's like no
this is all my homies think this
this isn't this is this isn't
controversial all my homies agree come
on Jews love money
just like Italians love pizza aliens
love pizza you know the Germans they
love their beer come on the Jews they
love their money it's the same positions
in their vodka
it's so [__] stupid bro
like what what stupid bro what's like a
I don't know it's just gross I can think
of more examples but they all probably
not great things to have sound bites
what's an accurate Italian uh analogy
for Joe because he goes oh Italians like
pizza
but it's like she was like money like
Italians love fascism yeah there that's
good yeah that's good
the Italians we love
our Mussolini
peppercini with our Mussolini
us Italians we love fascism
you actually here that's actually a
better comparison is like all Italians
or Mobsters like in the mob that
wouldn't be an actual Italians are frogs
right I love pizza and I love people
everybody knows every Italian's a thug
they can't be trusted they're violent
criminals psychotics
Joe
[Music]
I know you're Italian and so this
message might not get clear to you you
violent Thug
[Music]
put down the weights and listen to me
for Christ's sake this [__]
sucker Joe's the muscle he doesn't got
much brain
when we deliver the goods job right
there
like what do you think about it
yeah I'm not overreacting right that's
like psychotically anti-Semitic
do you think there's anything yeah and
it's it's just very you can tell it's
like so casual and like just kind of
ingrained uh because again The Wider
like he thinks he's like he's
interviewing uh her name's crystal ball
I think what the hell that's her name uh
yeah change that girl is that her is
that her real name or like a fake name I
think that's her real name crystal ball
oh that's not fair to her if that's real
I'm pretty sure it's real oh her parents
were what'd they do that day why'd they
do that oh I let me see into your future
I don't know maybe it is a stage name I
don't know I just know that she goes by
Crystal Ball Crystal with a K the way I
just looked up in Google crystal ball
and it showed me a bunch of crystal
balls it's good like glass crystals
she'll never beat uh she'll never be
number one on Google you just can't beat
the crystal balls they're too prolific
yes she well she knew what he was doing
and she she backed out real fast on that
one right yeah she's like no no no no a
left a left-leaning uh commentator and
yeah I mean the uh
The Wider conversation that was going
there was uh one that I don't
necessarily disagree with and he he
thought he was like
he thought he was being based to her
right there and like indeed I don't
think he even really registered how bad
that's I'm just gonna spit facts right
now hmm
Jews are greedy
I'm just going to say it plainly right
now I'm just spitting facts I'm just
spitting facts and anybody who says
that's anti-Semitic I mean come on it's
part of the conspiracy
hey Crystal Ball what does your crystal
ball say
sorry
[Music]
yes
so that's not the main story of today
but that was just like a little sneak
peek of do you think that there's
something to this idea that like because
it's anti people don't care that much
about anti-Semitism oh absolutely
uh because like people just enjoy in
general people don't get outraged
because like no they do that was pretty
bad and nobody talked about it well it's
just it's like I mean how often is job
popping off with stuff like this it's
like you only stay mad for so long
they've been trying to cancel this guy
for two or three years now it's not
happening and it's like that's true add
it to the pile right
yeah I think through my life though I've
definitely seen people being
anti-semitic more casually than
I
do think so I think the casualness
that people are anti-semitic is really
interesting yeah I think yeah it was it
depends a lot of when I was in high
school that was like always the punch
line of the jokes was a lot of
anti-Semitism [__]
no it was pretty ubiquitous for me
growing up too
I was uh
sitting with
a friend of mine and this other dude in
class when I was in high school
my dad owned a bike shop
and uh with two other guys and they were
all Jewish because they uh they're all
part of the fam uh you know part of the
same family
and um he goes yeah I used to work a
cycle scene that was my dad's shop
and my friend was egging him on because
he know he knows my dad owns the shop
he's like oh really so what did you
think about them over there he's like if
they're run by a bunch of Jews
and he's like really what's wrong about
he just he [__] him up it was really
funny but also like really sad
he's like what do you mean what's wrong
with Jewish people
and then once he got him to like fully
expose himself he's like you know his
dad owns cycle stream right
pretty good got him he was very
embarrassed but yeah got him there was a
casualness with that that yeah
also I feel that surprised me the the k
word gets thrown at least in my case
gets thrown around a lot we'll call you
that I've had it happen yeah
growing up people threw it out a lot I I
mean I think part of it too is just I'm
not an adolescent in high school where
people are edgy and saying [__] like
that all the time but yeah when I was a
kid people threw around the k word a lot
people say this a lot still don't don't
Jew me or whatever that's like insane to
me that's that's insane yeah yeah that's
crazy like what the [__] trying to Jew
me out of something what does that mean
like rip me off oh like Financial yeah
oh yeah
I don't want to make it sound like it's
it was just uh people are saying k word
we can say it right it's not like don't
say it okay we'll just look it up it's a
slur for Jewish people it's not for the
K you'll figure it out
um yeah I do want to say though that uh
that casualness um uh I agree definitely
existed growing up and and heard a lot
of it myself but I don't want at all to
Discount like at least in my experience
in the area that I grew up
so much just casual racism about
Mexicans and and right Latino people as
well um even though I mean my my schools
were like 70
Hispanic and people were still just
wildly racist against Mexican people
growing up so uh yeah uh Jews were not
the only one but
uh people are hateful everywhere yeah I
mean and again you don't look like me
it's also kids not not that totally
excuses it but like kids don't really
exactly well they just they inherit it
and they're not really thinking about it
and well and to be fair Joe Rogan does
have the uh maturity of an
eight-year-old right yeah you can let
him go on this one I think South Park is
to blame for a lot of that that's where
I first heard these terms to be honest I
would absolutely agree with that I never
thought about that and I'm a huge fan
one of them is wait really but yeah Matt
Stone is Jewish yeah okay he gets the
pass well and that's the thing is South
Park is uh it's satire but you don't
understand that as a kid right yeah like
you think Cartman's hilarious you don't
realize that he's like supposed to be a
[__] little [__] piece of [__] when
you're a kid you think he's yeah there
was so I knew so many kids that like
thought Cartman was so funny it was
great wait what did you learn from South
Park maybe not to I just curious which
is like because I knew all that [__]
obviously as a Jewish person I never
thought about it I didn't grow grow up
around any Jewish people to be honest
because where I come from is
predominantly Arab mm-hmm but uh I
remember hearing that term what the k
word k word I was on South Park almost
positive oh yeah
I remember
on that show that was wild dude in the
early Seasons well I mean I swear
everybody learned the F slur for for gay
people as well they said all the time on
that show Cartman what yeah they're
always calling each other yeah what you
don't remember this I don't remember it
was very casual it was on the show all
the time Cartman uh dressed up as Hitler
and marched around the town because he
loved Mel Gibson The Compassion of the
Christ or something like that like it's
[__] hilarious it is a funny show and
they went after everybody you know what
I mean yeah
but uh
yeah I same thing people say don't jip
me but once I realized that I was
talking about like Romanian people
literally me too you're not Roma people
or what it's different you said Romanian
that's not Romanian Roma
gypsies but they come from somewhere
isn't it Romania yeah it's a lot of
people get confused by that it's
Romanian people are different than Roma
where do gypsies come from uh well they
they come from a lot of places uh to
think the Balkans but they're nomadic is
the thing uh and so they they're all
over Europe it's similar to Jews how
um well they were all over the place and
uh
Northern India but lived in modern times
worldwide principally in Europe right
there you go the [__]
so wait Roma Romany
is considered a pejorative
Romney
Romani is considered a pejorative
uh well tell that to our chat because
they're all spamming in the chat right
now Hey where's your mouth watch your
mouth people
um yeah but a lot of people you're far
from the only person to confuse that I
think I thought that for a long time but
um yeah uh Romanian is different okay
well regardless
um once I realized what it what it was I
was saying because I didn't even realize
from I was like wait chips oh yeah same
I had no idea the word saying Egypt or
whatever I I didn't even make the
connection to Gypsy yeah just thought
that was just the expression people when
I first started here I said it and I was
like oh [__] I had no idea yeah
yeah that's like whoa
I got some [__] for saying uh spaz
recently spaz bass yeah oh yeah which is
like what I've been calling Lena for
years wait what's wrong with spaz
because it's short for [__] like
somebody who uh like having a like a
seizure uh like that or I guess maybe
even like uh you you you have spasms
from your Tourette's
I think a spasm is like a you can't it's
just like happens an involuntary yeah
involuntary right and so there's
somebody who's [__] is born with a
disability that makes it difficult for
them to control their muscles there you
go so that
that's an actual medical condition
[__]
right yeah people now refer to someone
with this disability as having Cerebral
Palsy
oh so it's like saying using the r word
for someone with cerebral palsy I guess
I guess so people say spaz is like the r
word in the UK well I think here now too
um [__] that's crazy
it's crazy a lot of the language that I
used as a kid that I know is super
offensive now that everyone was using
I had no idea
um
what the [__] it meant or what I was
even saying I think that's that's the
case for a lot of people that's why you
know
it's okay to uh to learn these things
and and and grow rather than you know
well you get so attached to it when you
use a word like the r word like
restarted it there's a certain level of
like
in terms of like how you describe things
people don't want to give that up but
yeah sometimes like of course I I don't
plan on saying it but like it's hard for
me to find a fill word when I've been
calling Lena espaz for years like I
don't know what's the what's the word to
insert there instead Lena how do you
feel about that he's basically are you
here Lena
all right
oh she's she's there okay Lena you're
back
I'm always in the vicinity I'm listening
yeah what's up so Abe's been calling you
a restarted
yeah the word before that he does he was
calling me that
um thoughts you want to know why why
oh I maybe you should explain maybe I
don't know why do you call me that
because sometimes she I don't know how
to describe it yeah me either
sometimes she she bugs out sometimes
what does that mean you bug out like
little neuroses I mean yeah that's
that's how I had always used it as well
wait hold on I want to know what bug out
means
Lena if you're comfortable
which what word means well what does bug
out mean
when she gets scared like when she
screams like what is she talking about
like okay we'll be sitting next to each
other and
the TV will challenge
easily maybe we could say that jumping
that makes sense
man you got it should be like she'll be
like what is that or did you do that I'm
like I don't know maybe it just turned
on or something I don't know but yeah I
have noticed that you you get spooked
easily yeah I'm jumpy is a good word for
it okay
so as a little spooked so I guess
I didn't know this now but spaz this is
it it's out it's out
no more
you gotta you're gonna have to redo that
AB well is snip's okay he calls me Snips
because of it too Snips that seems fine
okay it's offensive to people who are
circumcised to be honest but it's fine I
am deeply [__] offended Snips excuse
me I don't love it but I'll let it slide
how dare you
yeah so Joe Rogan's anti-semitic uh also
this so yeah he got there's this huge
Joe Rogan scam
and I've been talking about his
supplements being like pretty pretty
questionable
and then this video is making its rounds
sure enough Joe has
has uh well what can I say here he is
check it out check this out there's a
category of supplements that are very
interesting work very well to increase
testosterone by about 100 to 200 points
well look that Alpha grind product is
all over Tick Tock if you go to Amazon
and you type in libido booster for men
you're gonna find it right at the top
and that's because guys are figuring out
that it literally is increasing size and
making a difference now that stimulates
the testes if you got those to make more
testosterone or estrogen right why is
there a category of supplements that are
very interesting so these big scams are
here of course that's not Joe Rogan or
his guest having a serious conversation
but you know what's so funny is that
because this is especially compelling
because Joe Rogan does show this crap
yeah it's like it's close enough to
reality that it's believable like if it
was if it was I guess we should explain
that this is a deep fake and Fabrication
audio and everything and um yeah I mean
if somebody did this to you
you constantly [__] on like these
supplement companies and everything and
it wouldn't be believable but like you
said he he's showing them all the time
so it's like it doesn't seem like it's
hard I think yeah it doesn't seem like a
stretch at all and let's be honest Joe
Rogan listeners are probably not like
the highest IQ
how dare you they're more they're more
into T levels than IQ T high IQ low baby
okay
um here is
Hassan's editor I love this guy
um ostenox this guy is freaking
incredible
he re-did it so it sounds even better I
don't know why he did this for the
scammers I guess
well he was just trying to show uh that
because I mean frankly like that one
isn't that good like
Joe's watching yeah the voice is a
little off it doesn't really sync up and
so
he's just showing that um
he's they said they said they did in 30
minutes and with 30 minutes he made it
sound much better the original one was
made in like five minutes I don't think
that any time it all went into that
but here is the uh 30 minute improved
version there's a category of
supplements that are very interesting
work very well to increase testosterone
by about 100 to 200 points well look
that Alpha Grime product is all over
tickets
uh uh
it's probably a royalty-free one because
he threw it on to be shared around type
in libido booster for men you're gonna
find it right at the top guys are
figuring out that it literally is
increasing size and making a difference
down there everybody sounds way more
natural it looks so [__] real wait
the first half of the clip that's not
deep fake right
my automatic assumption was that they
just shot that guy in a room to look
like he was sitting across from Joe
Rogan and then
the opposite part of it because now this
guy this guy was a guest oh he was a
real good yeah and so he's just talking
about it hold on let me watch this
there's a category of supplements there
no this guy's deep fake too look at his
mouth it looks a little very interesting
it worked very well to increase
testosterone by about 100 to 200 points
yeah his voice movements are a little
uncanny I mean that looks [__] legit
yeah that's I mean so so this is the
Brave New World that we find ourselves
in eh
deep fake scams are here
surprised it took this long I'm gonna be
like hey a teeth incline today I'm
telling you to get do your sign up bonus
fedstate.com using my code HD but I
don't know what the [__] that was
it's a deep fake I'm deep undercover
meanwhile I'm getting paid that Aiden
Ross money
it was a deep fake man
ah yeah I'm Ethan Klein please buy my
supplements
to increase your testosterone
you know
pretty scary the way I'm sure that this
probably worked on a lot of people
you're pointing at yourself
love you it worked on you buy some of
this if you guys hadn't said anything
and like said you wanted to talk about
it today I wouldn't have thought twice
yeah yeah
I don't look that closely especially at
a video of Joe Rogan I'm not going to be
like
what's really saying I just
that looked real to me yeah I'm with you
100 I'm with you man
we need to see a uh a version of this
where they're selling mascara or
something and trying to pass it off in
front of Olivia and see because maybe if
you're more engaged with the content you
might have this messed up here uh really
increased my uh estrogen my titties grew
a whole cup size
from the mascara
can you do that cam is there like a app
or something
I'll look into it yeah let's get some
mascara
Joe Rogan I remember cam did it with um
I think it was for make Ethan laugh he
did it with uh uh Kim Kardashian's dad
it was actually Ethan's Dad yeah oh it
was Ethan's yeah yeah but that was my
voice though yeah we didn't we didn't he
didn't fake the voice yeah it was just
cam talking is Gary Right the the mouth
thing is kind of easy I guess yeah it's
wicked easy to do that but of course
it's the voice thing there it got like
pretty easy to do you just put it in
I don't know whatever and since you're
real good nice clickbait title though
it's not easy it's not easy
uh let's see internet scam featuring AI
version Joe Rogan went viral
the ad sees Rogan yada yada
yep
the version they are using is paywalled
oh really how much is it it could be a
worthy investment I love that [__]
how much is it love
I'm not sure but I think it's 11 Labs I
think it's called
let's buy it let's start doing it now
this is uh President Obama
I'm here to tell you that uh
you gotta have them ribs I'm a big fan
of H3 podcast
[__] too love Ethan love [__] too
gotta have [__]
dude that is the most worthy investment
we could possibly do
I mean Rogan uh talked about Jimmy Lee
on his show hmm
you know
well that one was real that was 100 yeah
right forgive me that one was real
um we got so much other stuff let's see
Andrew taint
this man's in jail rotting it's so
awesome
this man said
he tweeted out I updated my will from
prison I will be donating 100 million to
start a charity to protect men from
false accusations no you're not
no
nice try though
first of all there's no way he has that
much money I don't give a [__] how many
people he's trafficked
and second of all
[Music]
you definitely didn't do that
I'm the one getting plowed
God willing
we'll find out if it's true or not soon
also he and
why because you think he's gonna die
I didn't say anything about that well it
is what it is what did you mean I just
said God willing we'll find out in the
near future God wills it
God is great inshallah means God willing
and inshallah inshallah
what's the hand motion I should do with
that
inshallah
what's the hand motion Lena there's no I
mean if like if I'm imagining my mom
saying and she would just be like this
like and yeah
and
inshallah inshallah inshallah inshallah
God willing
in Hebrews baru Baruch Hashem Hashem
[Music]
he says I would never kill myself
okay I'm not suicide I knew it was
coming thank you Zach
there was actually he's been kind of
like uh set sad tweeting there was the
one where he's like I almost cried did
you guys see that one
where I'm trying to find that damn this
is big
it almost cried he almost had a real
human emotion for a second here but he
said that he didn't though right no he
he no he did not okay thank god oh thank
God no I mean so embarrassed Maybe
this like Dollar Store motivational [__]
from prison
I have small dick energy it's so [__]
stupid that people are actually still
are reading this God men are pathetic I
need to be their daddy how do I daddy up
for these boys you know what I saw on
the freeway on my way to work today it's
a banner over the freeway
um it said hashtag free Andrew Tate
I'm sure that's going to be a huge
influence over the Romania over the
Romanian traditional right I'm sure
they'll see it this Banner in Los
Angeles California
here he says
he goes
this man actually tweeted this out
lock yourself in your bathroom without
your phone or laptop and try to sit for
an hour
I'm at day 43 and Counting I almost
cried today almost
hey how about do that and then imagine
you've been Human trafficked by Andrew
Tay that's the game
three hundred thousand likes almost 23
24 million views for whatever the views
are worth I mean you know that's nothing
but please bring me pizza
poor Andrew Tate he almost shed a tear
so you're getting out soon
from his like temporary hold or whatever
they did another 30 days so he's got 60
days so he's got another two weeks
is he still Muslim is that still a thing
or is he over that face really seen any
mention of that no he is he is he's been
he tweets about Islam and stuff okay
cool because he's in prison now he's got
a yeah he's he's usually people go in
and get converted right exactly
brought it in there he's he's an
innovator
the man or I mean the man really already
thinks he's like a what do you call it
an Imam a prophet yeah is Heman Prophet
uh no not Imam Lina how would you
explain Imam it's like a leader right
like a rabbi priest right yes it's
higher up in his shirt yeah like a
bishop or something it's like a shack
with with Riz
yeah yeah he's an Imam
e mama
oy mama
that's what they always say
they come into the mask
the mommy is here the Imam Is Here Yeah
Andrew's mom's Andrew Tate is
uh sitting there Crying by himself so
not crying I almost cried today I almost
cried today I'm a bottom
I must cry today
but real men don't grow
guys I found this great testosterone
booster that make your balls gigantic
search on Amazon Ethan's ball magic for
only 9.99 get your balls looking like
mine it sounds kind of like Joe Rogan
and me crossover yeah I uh how'd you
make that yeah
why and she said how how uh it was using
uh the 11 Labs shout out to Ryan or
Harvey for doing it right Harvey the
girl oh he's yeah how do we make it
better
I think that's very good probably almost
as good as Ethan or The Joe Rogan one
there were certain words that were
really good there were others that were
uh yeah and I would have I didn't raised
an eyebrow if I had heard this without
any context I didn't think it sounded
like me at all oh we'll try again let me
try again I found this group I mean when
he says guys sounds like Joe Rogan but
then like as it goes on it sounds more
and more like you I read the music on
there
and boom you got an ad
guys I found this great testosterone
booster that it's still much like this
yeah
after the word booster and on it starts
to sound much more like you as I got a
little bit of a Kermit thing with a or a
Jordan Peter maybe they fed it with the
audio of the podcast and you do the damn
Jordan Peterson Impressions so much yeah
it could be that it guys I found this
great testosterone booster that make
your balls gigantic search on Amazon
Ethan's ball magic for only 9.99 get
your balls looking like mine it gets a
little better in the middle yeah yeah
yeah it's still it's not it needs some
work but it's not good that is very with
a very low amount of uh training
material too yeah I think that's the
thing you need to feed it a lot I love
the idea of just doing AI as of myself
for no [__] reason hey guys hey guys
it's Ethan Klein
get your balls super big
chicks love huge balls I'm saying it
sounds like the quartering
okay well let's not maybe because say
that again maybe because Jeremy himself
kind of sounds like AI well Ethan
IQ inbred exactly
Amy I gotta ask you something yeah
this was pulled as a receipt last or
like a couple weeks ago and I've been
meaning to ask you about it
um
one of the fans caught you in a pretty
egregious lie why does it lie
so I'm gonna need you to clarify here
okay so sure let me play this that makes
me think of my grandma's funeral me and
my cousins were all kicked out by my dad
bro
my cut real fast my cousin came in late
and he sits next to me in an Islamic
funerals you sit up all the men and
women the family set up at front on each
side
my cousin turns to me and say what did I
miss because he came in late and I said
turns out she's not dead and then it
just started
so in this recounting you are a
hilarious jokester who is so damn funny
you tore down the whole [__] funeral
okay yeah
and Dan loves it everyone's like damn
Amy's pretty funny guy yeah even love
was laughing I saw love laughing too so
so but then the second retelling has a
different twist to it
it started Chain Reaction they got us
all kicked out with my father because we
were sitting in front it could not stop
laughing
I have a I have a quick story that
relates go ahead I was late for my
grandma's funeral once and I walked in
late and I asked my cousin what did I
miss he said uh turns out she's not dead
and it made me laugh it made me baby
are you the hilarious jokester or did
you steal the Valor you think of your
cousin a few things
once I walk for one I think it kind of
proves that I actually happened now who
said it this is the second I'm literally
lying second thing is I will say I said
it I did lie the second time because the
context I didn't know I told the story
immediately after I did chat started
saying I'm like oh [__] I did tell the
story but I was trying to it was right
after the whole Chestnut situation and I
was trying to lighten the mood but also
I don't want people saying oh hey we
always tries to make everything about
himself so instead of saying I was so
funny and hilarious my cousin told this
story because this guy is against a
manipulative line icon I am being
persecuted for trying to be the good guy
Jesus bro you [__] if that's really what
happened you gotta you boy you're doing
this gymnastics in your head it's oh
yeah that's overthinking [__] like
that's my that's my daily life why are
you thinking so much about it it's crazy
yeah I don't I don't know I'm I think
it's a mix of like uh being anxious and
also
you know just my dad being an attorney
like everything we did was being
questioned and my cousin who I grew up
with always have an alibi yeah always
have even even if you're doing nothing
wrong have an alibi why does it lie so
so it was you who said the funny joke I
I am [__] hilarious yeah because I
heard in another version it was actually
your Grandma sat up and said it yeah
yeah it was like a weekend she said I'm
not dead yeah and then everybody laughed
yeah she was like surprised [__]
thumbs up surprise
all right so a b is the funny funny guy
funny guy did you hear the explanation
Dan
sorry I was in the bathroom is he a
Weasley little liar he says expected he
says he lied about it literally lying
uh-huh he did tell the joke and he lied
about it because the chestnuts thing
just happened and he didn't want to seem
insensitive like me
so really it's your fault
it's more of trying to get uh
he was trying to say something for you
yeah trying to cover for you
that's a lawyer see he laid on a grenade
for you Ethan I'm over this [__] nobody
who you are trying to call him out why
the [__] you lying
oh my God
whatever bro you just you tried to get a
janitor fired from
actually I [__] got him fired protect
yourself
wrong
okay I'm glad we got that sorted out
thank you baby thank God I was worried I
was gonna get fired no no no
I saw this Tick Tock this morning it's
kind of in the Alpha Brain world and I
just thought this is so this really
shows how dumb this [__] is
now ice baths is like the hot new thing
in the alpha World everybody's got to
take a ice bath
ice bath in the morning ice bath in the
afternoon we need we wake up we break
the ice we get in the ice water
everybody's doing it
I saw Russell Brand in the ice bath this
morning it's like everybody's in the
[__] ice bath that dude he that what
happened to him huh I mean I think he
was always a bit of a nut but he's
really no but this dude did one goddamn
episode with Joe Rogan and now look at
him
what happened bro
this is you on Alpha Brain he used to be
funny
now he's in an ice bath he was the lead
singer for one of the greatest bands of
all time infant sorrow now he's taking
[__] ice baths unbelievable
unbreakable we need someone to make
compilation of all your references
that's like your third movie reference
yeah yeah yeah so you got it I love his
song African Child it's great brush my
teeth to that [__] he was huge though he
was like uh the biggest act married to
Katy Perry yeah he was married he had it
all he was married to Katy Perry for
getting Sarah Marshall yeah yeah so now
he's in a [__] ice bath taking Alpha
Brain so what's the deal with the ice
bath I did a little bit of research
because part of me is like the skeptical
part of me is like there's no [__]
way that this ice bath
is that good for you
and what I found is that like for elite
athletes who are doing like insane
muscle training it can lower the um
what do you call it the inflammation
inflammation a little bit it's not
really even proven I mean it makes well
it intuitively makes sense because like
when your muscles are sore you put an
ice pack on it like yeah but you yeah
but you keep the ice on it here you go
and if you stand for more than three
minutes you got hypothermia
oh all right
they have some weird pseudoscience thing
where you shock the body and then it's
supposed to like give I don't know the
blood vessels
make the nipples bigger yeah maybe a
nipple yo we call Doctor wait I wonder
if Dr IDs can chime in on this
what is a nutritionist I guess he knows
everything bro he knows more than
everything I mean [__] people said do an
ice bath up Ethan did a nice bath I did
the show and he ate raw meat did you
guys forget
yeah I I think ice baths can be useful
in a very limited setting for extreme
athletes not like not like Derek in his
backyard
because he wants to prove something it
you're somewhat in insulting Love's
culture here because he mentioned before
the show that um it's a it's pretty
popular in Sweden right well Sweden but
more importantly or more more in Finland
but yeah it's a little bit of a thing
here not massive but in Finland it's
every every night I think really no
shots but it's like it's a typical thing
like you take an ice bath and then a
sauna that's like a classical
yeah but
I kind of feel like they just kind of
stole it from us we're doing it as like
more of a social thing
and it is nice it gives you a nice
feeling when you take a dip and then go
into the sauna directly it's nice sure
there's no there's no major like weird
bro signs behind it's just do it it
feels kind of nice and then going to the
sauna and refreshing uh chill with the
boys you know a little bit of a sauna
with the boys come on I get that that
sounds fun right that's nice well I saw
this guy
and I'm like dude
you don't have to do this this guy he's
Jordan makes vids on Tick Tock this is
day 59.
of his ice bath and listen to what he
says about it
morning guys it is day 59 of taking a
nice bath every single day
and I gotta be real with you I feel like
quitting
I don't want to do this today I stood
there staring out the window
procrastinating for the last 20 minutes
thinking about all the excuses that I
had not to do this
I didn't sleep well last night I'm tired
my kids are sick I woke up with anxiety
and then I thought to myself with all
those things stacked against me what if
I could still pull this off dude listen
listen to all the reasons this is
ruining your life isn't it supposed to
help you feel better he's like I can't
sleep I wake up anxious I stare out the
window and pear and Dread it's just like
forlorns wait a thousand yards wait it's
it's not helping you it's it's making
your life worse stop doing it man
look I'm 40. I'm tired it's like I'm
sweaty what happened to the benefits
isn't it supposed to make you feel good
it's not working for you bro or just or
just take the day off just skip no it is
okay then I thought to myself but he
goes he goes no I thought to my ear my
kids are sick his kids are sick from
sitting in the ice
[Laughter]
I woke up with anxiety and then I
thought to myself with all those things
stacked against me what if I could still
pull this off and so that's what I'm
gonna do it's minus four degrees Celsius
out here this morning I didn't but I
know you can pull it off you're just
sitting in water
like theoretically it's not that hard
it's quite easy actually yeah just
unpleasant as as you're clearly laying
out here to the extent that I continue
to torture myself bearing out the window
dreading I woke up this morning oh God I
couldn't sleep I haven't slept in days I
just think about the ice
but I'm still gonna do it because
apparently it helps me in some way
temperature it's one degree Celsius
we're gonna do three minutes in the ice
bath
no matter what's going on in my mind
right now
still going to be a good day
[Applause]
it's components can you stay true to
what you said you were going to do long
after the mood that you set it in it's
gone bro it's so this is like part of
this kind of it's okay to change your
mind bro if you realize it's not helping
you it's not a good idea
like
like I get the dedication is good and
discipline is good
but it's okay to change your mind dude
and I think it would it would be an
easier sell if it was something other
than nice like if he's talking about
like
he's dedicated to going on a mile jog
every morning great and he wakes up in
the morning this one morning and just
like God I really don't want to do this
but you know what I'm going to push
forward
that's understandable and you know good
for you but with the ice bath it's just
out of I probably could skip a day I
mean he might really be like that much
this morning I
didn't want to put bamboo shoots under
my nails
but I pledged I do it I said I would for
60 days the man is dedicated he's
wearing Detroit Lions shirt and hat that
shows dedication because we suck so
anytime you're from Detroit I don't
think
this guy just hates his life
I laid down this morning on a bed or on
the [__] drawn quartering machine
I didn't want to get dropped in quarter
this morning you know what you know what
today I said I would today this morning
I stepped into the Iron Maiden
I knew I it just motivates me and I
I don't like it I have angst I have
panic attacks all day
my skin is bleeding I can't eat
my kids say I've changed my wife is
leaving me
but I'm dedicated
and this is helping me somehow
see motivational get you started without
discipline without me we'll never finish
stop making excuses
get up
and finish what you started bro it run
out of things he's repeating himself now
but like I don't want to
go to sleep with fear
that's not motivational bro you don't
have to make yourself miserable you you
you are you might as well just go live
in Guantanamo Bay bro if you think it's
so dope
you know
just go live on this just be homeless I
mean if that's the uh just go
what's the point here
some days you just don't have it
but discipline doesn't get a saddest
[__] video I ever seen no matter how
you feel some days
my life is falling apart you really did
not have a much material to Vamp for
this long he's just been in the wheels
here
he's having a rough day Dan it's a rough
day do it anyway nice
I'm already sad my kids are dying
my wife left me bro get out of the ice
the ice is ruining your life can't you
see it
very sweet that he kept the Hat on he
needs it because yeah he does no his
microphone is on there even though he's
pointing away from his mouth
what is that hat doing audio is actually
pretty good quality yeah yeah pretty
good but he's a giant [__] because his
head is warm he dunks he doesn't have
the distance he takes it off and dunks
at the end of the video okay good
you just gotta remember [__] these two
shall pass
you did it to yourself This Too Shall
Pass you you didn't have to have
something to pass
you're the one that got in the bath
it'll pass when you get out of the bag
you get out of the bath and then you you
don't go in it again and then it's
passed
what's passing I don't understand
all right time's up
forever
I don't know I I felt like wow these
guys have gone too far this video is sad
as [__] and it's so silly I feel like
it's like simulated struggle because
they can't have like a very hard life
outside of this so they have to like
force themselves to do these arbitrary
weird-ass things right that's a good
idea I'm sure if they actually have a
hard life you're not gonna be like oh I
gotta do a [__] ice path right now
before I work 12 hours at the [__]
Factory no game probably has an ECS life
no yeah I guarantee you there's no
Indian Street vendors who work 20 hours
a day yeah like I'm going for the ice
bath dip afterwards
yeah this guy is so motivational that's
the top comment he is the opposite of
motivation to me I think this guy is
[__] looks so sad
and I do not want to be like this man
which is sad the the underlying you know
uh the message of motivation again like
substitute in going on a jog for two
months straight or whatever or something
a little bit
more listening tangibly beneficial than
the ice bath I didn't want to drink
bleach this morning but I said I
dedicated to myself my organs are
failing I can feel it if I drink another
sip I might die but I'm dead this is
what discipline is
you know what I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna do that Dan with jog every morning
I'm gonna make one of these videos
well that's fine and that one yeah that
would be motivational that'd be great
I'd be happy for you
thank you happy for you bro
we're sorry
today I'm gonna be eating 10 Twinkies
for breakfast
it's all about dedication
I haven't [__] in 10 days
yeah but I made a goal and I'm gonna
stick to it
yeah it's great the Bros Science World
needs a reality check these guys are so
far gone
yeah I don't know
today I stared at the Sun for a minute
it really hurt thought the Sun from
being I can I can feel my vision I could
still deteriorating hours later the big
bright burning ball I'm dedicated
God damn it I've woke up this morning I
could see the sun when my eyes closed
and I didn't want to wake up
I got panic attacks when I see the sun
but I still had to look at it didn't
wake up
so Dr IDs is going to call in apparently
I want to get his take on the ice bath
I would I think it has limited benefits
you know and and specific situations
that's my take on it
yeah we're talking about he he'll be
home soon he said
well if he just comes in and owns us
right now it's like no actually the
research says this is massively
beneficial mental and physical health
this man will live forever yeah 46 every
ice bath you take as a year onto your
life
[Laughter]
watch me tomorrow morning in the ice
bath
[Music]
I can set it up for all for all of us
that'd be let's do the whole show nice
Beth [__] it oh
so while we wait for our lovely uh
uh doctoral
expert
let's talk about something quick and S
easy here a quickie
I don't know how quick and easy what
about the buccal fat removal Trend
that's not quick no
it's there's a whole freaking uh
PowerPoint slideshow how about we talk
about uh Megan Fox and MGK Los Tacos
talk about it's still the T that's a
quick one uh Los Tacos Hermanos says I'm
in I'm from Norway it's dark here all
the time taking the ice bath wakes you
up that's all it does yeah right you
could see it it wake me up for sure cold
water wake you up real quick you know
there it is
okay that this I just can't believe it I
thought I love is not real Megan Fox and
MGK broke up
devastating right this is so [__]
devastating devastating
Megan posted a cryptic video
that said you can taste the dishonesty
it's all over your breath
lyrics oh no it's a Beyonce lyrics from
Lemonade she switched sides
she's she's quoting Beyonce now these
two are they're they are mentally 14
years old but yeah it is like the the
kind of emo Like post vague post with
song lyrics describing your feelings
thing but look at all these people
enabling it that's the problem
Megan Fox age
36. I'm just saying to be honest
everything that she did I was down with
because it seems like he cheated on her
so whatever her responsibility is like
drag him drag him down
they're [__] disgusting he sucks I
think he cheated on her literally Megan
then posted selfies one of which she's
posing with another man with Beyonce
again
uh oh same quote
what now dude
uh oh
you can taste the dishonesty it's all
over your breath
although Beyonce did forgive am I
supposed to go down more oh Beyonce did
forgive who the [__] is that
looks like he's do has camouflage also I
noticed I don't think anyone else went
into the wall he's halfway cloaked
bottom right of that photo there is a
person
who are you where'd she come oh my God
what is happening in this photo it's
like an AI generator but this this looks
like a public bathroom not like a place
where I can't get over this dude what it
is touching her he's turning on his
cloaking field it looks like Madame too
so like she's taking a picture with the
wax figure yeah for real wait what is
with his complexion
it's so weird
she found her lighting she sure did
she sure did
I said is that a hitman
he's speaking up on it I know it looks
like he wrote Snapper or something
who are you bro
it looks photoshopped
who is this or something like
like
[__] what year is it
holy [__] that's so funny
[__] did she just did he just take this
photo and she's like that photo is the
one I look best in so I'm gonna post it
no matter who the [__] else is in it I
don't know what else is going on
foreign
City of Phoenix he's just he's just in
some public restroom
City of Phoenix yeah
oh probably at the uh Super Bowl
oh that makes sense yeah
but she's still in a public restroom
true
anyone here from Arizona yes sir hey oh
yeah so do we know who he cheated on her
with
no not speculation
this whole thing is speculation
to be honest well one of their reps
announced that the here at the end it's
I mean
it's speculation but her implication is
pretty clear right yeah the quote the
quote also the Beyonce songs about
if it was anyway if it was anyone else
besides them like Dan said they're 14
year olds trying to be edgy like I could
see them doing the [__] either for
publicity or just temporary like
break
um the song's about cheating
I'm on
them like I'm choosing to believe that
it's it's done like her
engagement ring there was a lot of
toxicity what was that like he explained
that he put thorns on the bottom so that
it hurts her physically if she tries to
take it off awesome that's love right
there and she said he was like love is
pain
maybe love to you his face
is there a picture of her ring yeah I
want to see that
what does your ring look like Machine
Gun Kelly how about you put a [__]
Detonator on your [__] that you can
press if you ever cheat on her
I'm without a doubt pretty sure that
guy's a Prince Albert like he seems the
type of Duty yeah I could see that I
still love MGK I love his music you did
why
yeah dude I'm guilty and you see you do
strike me as a MGK fan I mean you love
Creed I do love Creed
I do of course oh [__] Chad is saying he
cheated with this guitarist that girl's
a fan
she's a fan bro I've connected with her
we sent her Teddy fresh and [__] it I
don't think it's proven exactly yeah
it's just it's just yeah it's
speculation I believe that there was a
comment or Megan responding to a comment
saying did did MGK get with Sophie is
her name and then Megan responded saying
uh how do you know I didn't get with
Sophie
how do you don't really mean anything I
didn't get with Sophie referring to
Megan having relations with that that is
I get it far from
I don't hmm
so they're so cringy
because like she like
I'm trying to decode that
she doesn't want to absolve her what is
this
what'd you owe it this
is
did you guys see this we were there dude
I forgot
so I guess I can't see the
I can't see the spikes on the bottom
the bands are actually Thorns so if she
tries to take it off it hurts love is
pain grow up
I thought you were just making that up I
didn't see the caption holy [__] oh yeah
oh my God
okay well okay we don't know if why do
you guys think it was a good the Tardis
the guitarist because I I don't want to
put anything out there she's a friend of
the show kind of I think people might
have said that because she is a fan of
the show
no you think they're just giving a nod
because they know we've talked about it
before okay yeah I I don't we don't know
she shreds she's super cool
amazing guitars it's awesome love she's
the best
hell no she wouldn't do that I think she
should be leading and and and machine
guns should take a [__] backseat oh
he can't play for [__] [__] she
Treads a [__] amazing like she didn't
like playing guitars
never mind I don't want to get into it
well we will follow the story closely
but Dr IDs is on the phone so let's talk
to this oh no he's not
oh is he not Olivia please
he's ready but he is not on the line yet
well
um
the good news to uh oh the single men I
guess is that
Megan Fox's single he's available wait
wait the best part of the story what's
the best part the bottom
before okay so by the way she deleted
all their photos together so that's
pretty like that was the first like
people are like what happening and then
came before deleting her entire
Instagram account all together Megan
followed three people Eminem Harry
Styles and Timothy chalamet and she
followed zero people before
that is
they're so embarrassing I think it wrong
just be an adult I know but it's like
dude stop it so embarrassing she's gonna
be 40 soon and all this silly [__]
ring with thorns and all this emo [__]
is not going to be cute it's going to be
sad yeah I think that when she started
dating him she kind of adopted the
cringe that was him 100 so I'm gonna let
her shed this and I'm gonna let her do
whatever and hopefully a year from now
the cringe is only with him 100 right
she was always so cool before this
no one really like didn't like her can I
ask you is Eminem still cool with this
[__] Avatar I'm no but it's cool I
think that she followed him just because
they have such a public beef
he's such a [__] dweeb he used to be
whoa whoa he's so old he's oh he's old
guys
it just sucks to see because he he's
people say he's the greatest rapper ever
right and and well he was who says that
no a lot of people say no a lot of
people say that yeah top five
but you know it's like when you get old
you sometimes just [__] lose it man
he's 50.
he's always right at all time Eminem
Macklemore machine gun
no stop Dan don't be like that other
records
a lot of other rappers have a good dude
from Smash Mouth I mean that verse on
All-Star don't stop coming stop coming
down and hit the ground running
that's true he that he is a good rapper
[Music]
um
well
so she she's thinking do you do you
suppose her following those three people
is her saying she's interested in them
romantically
I don't I mean who knows if she'll
pursue it but I think that that's the
message she was sending is like I have I
have plots now I have options well
following Eminem's definitely because
they had that public holiday yeah oh
oh she's and is it was I married so uh I
was looking at their age you know
Timothy is not I think he's dateable at
27.
for her she's what 36 you said
that's not that bad yeah Eminem is not
married I'd let it I'd let it go nine
years he's old enough Harry Styles is
29. y'all hate to tell you all you style
heads but this dude's getting old
all the style heads this man's about to
be 30.
you're gonna have to find a new crush
so is he getting I feel like his fans
are growing too so maybe that's power
grows every day yeah no the age of his
funds they're getting older you think
yeah he could be any age he sold out the
[__] Forum like a month in a row like
every night it was insane yeah they're
definitely his fans are growing up with
him
like though I think that the fans who
loved him since One Direction who
followed him when he started his solo
career
they're still there
update to the story according to People
magazine they haven't officially called
off the engagement but Megan took her
ring off
ow that must have hurt yeah
how did you do it I love his pain I took
it off with a uh
the band saw they have had issues in the
past but things seem pretty serious this
time
oh brother
Rory asked have you guys seen the video
of MGK saying that he's attracted to
Kendall Jenner when she was 17 he was
23. awesome yes we have pull it up since
we're waiting we have dude that video is
oh crazy
he is so crazy he goes yeah she's 17 so
what rock stars [__] kids
rockstars have a long illustrious
history of [__] kids he literally
said that
yeah I love that video I'll pull it up
for you
we use 23 or something in this video I
think
according to that comment yes
and so she's 18. I'm not waiting till
she's 18 I'll go now I'm 23 dog like
can we find one without like some weird
why the [__] it always does I think it
might actually be burned into the
interview what yeah I remember some some
sweet country twang yeah I want to [__]
a kid
oh
[Music]
uh real quick this is important uh a
message from uh Ela just came through
yeah
Teddy she said from Teddy ten dollars
thank you Ted
sweet boy
love that he loves playing with phones
now and he loves taking pictures It's
the funniest thing doing videos
and uh he sends me messages like this so
it's very sweet hi teddy love you
I'll be home soon we can I can confirm
that that music is in the original
version
that's what I remembered well here here
it is who's your first celebrity crush
oh see they they thought this would be
cute but then he's like no I want to
[__] kids
they're like who's your first crush
you know what it must be it must be
something with the Kelly Family
R Kelly MGK what's going on with these
Kellys
the Kelly Brothers
I don't care my first celebrity crush
was because right now it's Kendall
Jenner
damn it I'd say that so many
[__] times I hope that y'all
don't let me move to L.A dude the music
is so [__] terrible he's like man
don't let me near La cause I will hunt
hurt that child down
so inspirational
I will take her across state lines lock
her up
put her in the webcam service yes sir
dude money did good for him man he
looked like a
he was 16 is the age of consent I think
he must have done a lot of work because
he yeah he did a hair transplant did
hair he did he must have done his teeth
too many other times like I think he
must have uh
he also fixed this weird thing with the
he has metal in his mouth I don't know
what that is
God
funny joke there huh
thank you I hope that he's snagging that
don't let me move to L.A are you finding
her countdown to days until she's 18.
I'm not wait until she first of all that
question on face should never be asked I
think he's I think they're trying to
give him an out he's like yo don't let
me near her school don't let me near her
boy it's not that bad I'll find her
somewhere boy
so you counting down the days till she
turns 18.
[__]
she's 18 I'll go now I'm 23 dog like I'm
not like a creepy age like you know what
I'm saying I'm 23 bro she's 17 and I
mean it's not whatever you're saying is
very creepy 23 [__] you know I mean
oh dude I'm not a creepy age I just want
to find her I'm gonna look in her window
stalker learn her pattern her behavior
people need to keep I would away from
um like to retract my statement about
MGK
[Music]
you knew all this Zach right and more
importantly you've heard his music so
that's that's even worse this is this is
[__]
so what did he do what work did he do I
mean he did his hair for sure
I mean yeah it's it's just I think it
might just be that he just changed his
look a little bit yeah
maybe a tiny bit but
um Dr IDs now is in the waiting room if
you would like to uh return a celebrity
bring them over there's no limits right
there Robert Plant who is one of the
greatest lead singers ever for all y'all
don't know he's home for Led Zeppelin
date of the girl that was 14. Axel Rose
who was one of the biggest badasses ever
dated a girl that was 16. I wrote a song
on his first album about the girl that
was 16. I've studied this yeah I don't
know believe me I know judge me
regret is that Kendall's not 14.
what's uh
cleanse the palette for a second of the
underage talk before we bring in Dr Ed
wait wait what is this one I know I've
seen this okay so I just saw a picture
of Eminem's daughter I have to say she's
hot as [__] and the most respectful way
possible because m is King wasn't his
daughter wait what's the backstory I
believe the daughter was like 13 when he
died
yep
what
foreign
16 and 22. 16.
they were actually 16.
yes thank you thank you for correcting
that holy [__] all right I'm bringing in
Dr IDs
it's not
greet him with a bunch of pedo talk go
ahead here we go bring him in
hey Trader
okay uh uh doctor are you there
hello yes
I'm always saying I'm always there Dr
Edge thank you for joining us as always
my pleasure my pleasure thanks for
reaching out the question today is ice
baths it's popular on the Bro Science
World ice baths every day all the time
we watched a video of a guy he was like
this is my 49th day of doing an ice bath
I'm miserable I hate it I have anxiety I
can't sleep I procrastinate looking out
the window because I dread going in
there so much but I'm doing it because
I'm dedicated
um
is there benefits to doing these ice
baths to that level
that you know of right so
yeah this is there's lots of avenues to
this one question because first of all
the context in which they are doing it
so this gentleman you're talking about
is he doing it as like a one thing in
the morning is it for one minute is it
for Less is it for 10 minutes he does it
for three minutes every morning
and the water is like one or two degrees
Celsius and he showed it was actually it
was negative four outside where he was
doing he was in Canada and it was below
zero fahrenheit
um the water was one or two degrees
Celsius right very very very cold
okay interesting yeah so this is part of
the field of cold immersion therapy or
like cold water immersion therapy
um and there's actually been some decent
data on it for
I think the strongest evidence for it is
going to be surrounding post exercise
Muscle Recovery right so I know that
there's a recent
um analysis in Twin last year
that compared lots of different types of
kind of active recovery so things like
massaging foam rolling you know like a
light bicycle ride kind of after your
exercise session and they found that the
cold water immersion it might not have
been as cold as what you what you guys
are talking about but um a few minutes
of that within an hour or two after your
exercise session does seem to improve
the rate at which you recover from
exercise
um
but in terms of in terms of so there's
there's differences in the in the
science so you've got things like cold
shower like cold showers right where
they're not as cold as like an ice bath
there's some emerging evidence showing
that people who suffer with anxiety
[Music]
um they can have a reduction in their
heart rate or their symptoms of anxiety
and actually one actually very
interesting study I saw I think a few
months ago
was people who had cold showers compared
to the other group that didn't have the
cold they had normal temperature showers
they reduced the amount of days that
they called in sick to work and that was
a randomized control trial
um
so there are lots of emerging
interesting kind of Health outcomes and
cold water immersion uh fields of Health
that we're going into now however the
evidence for any one of them isn't
particularly convincing
that there are sporadic uh kind of you
know sporadic uh pieces of evidence that
we have to try and make a hypothesis by
like accumulating them all together
because they use different exposures
they use different types of cold water
immersion a cold showers different to an
ice bath an ice bath is different to
hydrotherapy you know they're all kind
of different in a sense
so it wouldn't really be wise to make a
generalized statement to say oh you know
an ice bath in the morning for three
minutes is going to be good for your
anxiety when there's only been pieces of
data to support that
um so yeah it is quite interesting well
there it is
um
it seems that we are getting a timid
rating of potentially interesting
yeah I would say definitely as in the
next five ten years we'll see a lot more
evidence on it however it should be
stated that in some people who do suffer
with anxiety or depression I know that
there were some reports of it actually
increasing uh heart rate increasing
blood pressure in some people
um and in some people who might be a bit
sensitive to it it can actually increase
stress and increase cortisol levels this
guy was he was stressed out because of
the ice bath
oh he's like I don't want to do it I'm
having existential dread
but I'm gonna do whatever keep doing it
every morning
but so why was he doing it in the first
place that's a good very good question
because it's a Vibe it's cool no I think
he thinks it is beneficial uh and it was
more like the the point of the video I
guess you could say was that it was it
was motivational it was like if you
dedicate yourself to something you
should do it even if you don't want to
kind of thing and I guess he had set out
to do this for 60 days in a row let's
show him it's short I'll show you the
video right yeah and part of it is like
15 seconds right yeah yeah
yeah so what are you seeing these days
uh what's what's rubbing your tits these
days on tick tock
oh there's what isn't I just uh today
I've just responded to someone who said
that the modern kind of agricultural
practices are decreasing nutrients in
our fruits and veggies by quite a lot
and she made the claim that uh in order
to get the same amount of iron from an
Apple today you would have to eat uh no
you would have to to get the same amount
of iron and apple from 1914 you'd have
to eat 25 apples today
[Music]
I was like sorry number one where does
that come from number two apples are not
a source of iron anyway it contains like
one percent of your of your daily intake
of ions Who the hell's eating apples for
iron like it makes no sense right and uh
and then when I called her out on it she
like
tried to claim that I was you know
inciting I was harassing her or bullying
her whatever I just said I just said
show me I just said show me the evidence
and she cites me a National Geographic
article
I was like great okay I love it they say
they putting out like this junk science
and then when you try to correct them
it's harassing and bullying it's like
grow a paragraph right you're entering
the public discourse you have ideas
let's let's challenge them and I like to
think that I remain relatively
respectful I don't insult anybody I
don't call anyone names right and
apparently to me yeah yeah like Ethan
you know you can do that for me it's
fine yeah
um carnivore MD's a [__] loser freak
bro honestly you know he made me call
him twice on Zoom prior to our debate
yeah I said what's the point of us
calling if you're just gonna make us
talk beforehand he goes oh I just want
to understand your position a bit more
right so I spend half an hour digging
into his his terrible studies he shows
me right and I do that twice I spend an
hour of my own time talking to him prior
to debating on your platform
and then the day before he goes yeah
sorry yeah no let's leave it he wanted
to see how embarrassed he was gonna get
yeah
dude and then I started telling my
audience like look just because he knows
he probably wouldn't have a chance
so he wanted to use those calls to see
if I had any good arguments
and the level of evidence he showed me
was absolutely atrocious it was so bad
and uh yeah I'm not surprised in the end
really I'm not surprised can I ask you a
question what are your thoughts on um
uh what hold on one sec I gotta recall
the name of this what are your thoughts
on this uh
uh what is it called God damn it here it
is vinyl chloride uh do we like
breathing Vinyl chloride how do we like
that do we drink it or do we avoid it
what is that
there was a massive oh you don't know
what Vinyl chloride is no okay so that's
fine it's just a joke sorry there was a
huge catastrophe in Ohio where it leaked
a bunch it's apparently super toxic oh
yeah but here's the video so I'll just
show it to you it's only like 20 seconds
go on
morning guys it is day 59 of taking a
nice bath every single day
and I gotta be real with you I feel like
quitting
I don't want to do this today I stood
there staring out the window
procrastinating for the last 20 minutes
thinking about all the excuses that I
had not to do this I didn't sleep well
last night I'm tired my kids are sick I
woke up with anxiety and then I thought
to myself with all those things stacked
against me what if I could still pull
this off and so that's what I'm gonna do
it's minus four degrees Celsius out here
this morning water temperature
one degree Celsius
we're going to do three minutes in the
ice bath
no matter what's going on in my mind
right now
still going to be a good day
that's it you know he gets in he does
the ice bath thing
but okay that's that's that's very
interesting because
I think this this highlights that
um we need to be very
reflective and kind of conscious of to
the effects of these things on ourselves
individually right so even though there
may be some benefits in some people some
people may you know train their vagus
nerve to activate the parasympathetic
system so it calms them down it chills
them out right people who have lots of
like daily stressors who are very
stressed in their daily life that's fine
those people might find benefit however
if you're finding that actually you're
dreading going to do it and you're
you're kind of you're generating your
own anxiety and stress you know going to
do it every day and you're not finding
benefits in your quality of life then
like you know why are you carrying on
that was my reaction you're right
I think I think it's good to do it's
good to like do a habit that you're not
very comfortable with to start if you
know that there are proven benefits
right so like a common one would be
something like increasing the amount of
fiber through fruits and vegetables in
your diet right some people initially
might get you know high levels of gas or
bloating or maybe you know their bowel
movements might be odd like to begin
with what do you mean odd
so people that aren't used to having
high fibrous Foods their gut can take a
disliking to it initially so they might
get a bit of diarrhea a bit of
constipation they might get a bit of
bloating their belly might goes out a
little bit I just wanted to describe
like the different kinds of poops you
might have okay yeah yeah there are lots
of different poops there's like uh in
hospital we have a stool chart for
different patients and um we we label
them type 1 type 2 type 3 Type 4 poo and
it's like we have different there's four
main categories there's like six there's
like six okay what are they um do you
know off the top of your head well it
basically it you so you've got rabbit
drops like if it looks like rabbit
droplings that's like one like really
hard like really like bitty like pebbles
right yep
um then you've got like the other end
which is like complete slosh like liquid
yeah yeah like imagine just like a just
like a Diet Coke
I had a um
I had a
I was on antibiotics and then I got this
really crazy thing did I ever show this
to you my pesto shits no can we show
them a picture
do you mind looking at it does he want
to see that was it was it green or red
pesto dude it was green it was like neon
green dude all glow in the dark
yeah it was uh does anyone have that
access to that the person it's on your
Twitter right we're gonna go find it
he posted it well we were talking about
it so much that I I decided I'm just
gonna put it up there for anyone that
wants to see
but I was after antibiotics yeah after
antibiotics here it is
oh God are you ready doctor wait come on
can we show it on screen no don't right
so let's switch off right we can't
because we have to switch to him from
here I I have a way to do it um just Ian
will just stay on you and I will uh swap
what's being sent to doctor all right
tell me when you're ready uh Dan in one
second
[Music]
um I must shut it to everybody yeah
oh here all right so now in a moment he
should see your screen okay yeah he's
seeing your screen now all right so here
it is Doctor is get ready yep
I was doing a school sample that's what
it looked like
wow that's like other words you ever say
anything like that
that's like it looks like a planet
it's so nasty God I can't even look at
it it makes me sick yeah that was coming
out of me it's crazy I never I never
knew it could be green like that and
it's like it's vibrant green
yeah yeah that's like um
actually post
anti-antibiotic diarrhea is quite common
actually really that color
no no not that color but just but just
just the concept of having distorted
bowel movements for a while is is is
pretty common
um what antibiotics were they just by
curiosity
gosh I don't even remember it was a
while ago now what was it I was taking
them for I don't even remember what were
they for like what was the illness
that's what I'm trying to remember
she did oh what was that no they thought
I had might have seeds Oh I thought that
I thought that's what you had no they
were saying you were just really ill
right and like you went to the hospital
and yeah but it was after I had been on
antibiotics for like a week
so that's what I mean you were just you
were really ill so you got on
antibiotics and then it made it made you
worse
I don't remember what my illness was
though but anyway was it ill with the
poops or something else no it wasn't
poop related at all I know right okay A
little bit of like a guacamole there
with maybe like garlic you ever you
think about maybe taking a tortilla chip
to that stop I thought it looks like egg
drop soup in my opinion right I see that
well except green
right I'm surprised surprised there's no
sweet Court in there
there's no way sweet corn there's no
sweet corn corn yeah mmm yummy terrific
well there it is okay so so
um that is very green so there it is
Doctor is you heard it here
[Applause]
like that in your career
um I've seen some pretty bad ones with
blood and like clots of mucus and stuff
in it especially after Bowser Alfredo
where are you going don't go back there
uh yeah that's uh that's uh that sounds
bad but the green color yeah that color
I've not seen There It Is I've not seen
that it's a medical uh it's a medical
mystery you are
you're very special my bowels are very
special glad to show you something new
for the first time doctor no that was
that was insightful yeah all right well
thank you for the input there uh Dr is I
appreciate you calling in as always
the one thing just one thing I will say
I forgot to mention about cold baths
is that I would not recommend it at all
for anyone who's got pre-existing
cardiovascular disease heart disease
um anyone that's had a prior history of
stroke or they're on the risk for stroke
because
when you immerse your body in extremely
cold water
your body responds by vasoconstricting
your vessels right so it Narrows your
vessels right meaning so if you've
already got con if you've already got
narrowed blood flow because you've got
plaque and your arteries are a bit
narrow right you've got you've had
Strokes or previous occlusions in your
vessels then by further constricting it
you could cause something called
ischemia which is a lack of oxygen and
nutrient Supply to your tissues
so you might make the problem even worse
well don't worry Dr Edge Joe Rogan's
heart is perfectly healthy and
definitely not enlarged from years of
human growth yeah he's he's good uh
don't worry Dr IDs after 20 years of
eating only elk meat and egg yolk and
taking youth human growth hormone I'm
sure his heart is in perfect condition
I'm such a sucker
yeah
yeah I hope I hope I hope most of his
audience have sense enough to not they
don't
probably uh well I can still hope I hope
your audience has enough sense actually
nobody here has taken ice baths to
guarantee that we're not the type of
people doctorates
good I'm glad all right listen uh thank
you so much always a pleasure
thank you very much the good doctor
appreciate you and I appreciate you
always always uh able to get on a call
with us uh you're the man Dr IDs ladies
and gentlemen Tick Tock Marvel tip God
legendary doctor researcher thank you my
friend extraordinaire are you still
single doctor there's lots of inquiries
in chat I am I am hopefully sometime
this year within the next 12 months I do
want to settle down okay okay a doctor's
looking to settle down girls just saying
uh oh when you mention your doctor dude
the faces light up of the women uh in
general when you speak to them
uh
uh usually
they know that I'm a doctor before they
know me
so your reputation precedes you like I I
don't ever just walk around go hi if you
didn't know I'm a doctor right you don't
find yourself in situations like at a
bar having a pint or you put you don't
drink do you I don't drink yeah I don't
drink yeah so there that is so yeah I
mean
you got to swing that around a little
bit
yeah the doctor title what do you guys
think of saying not not his dig
well if you guys can get if you guys can
get me a wife that'll be that'll be all
right okay okay we can
make anything I don't know all right
doctor thank you so much
thank you appreciate you yeah
this man's a doctor he's not even out
there
swinging it around
I'm a doctor I'm a doctor
[Music]
Dr Reagan Fox just became available
so true
someone should tell him just saying it's
a big step Up MGK all right let's see we
got we covered a lot the UFO sightings
we didn't I guess we can do that on
Wednesday they'll probably be more by
then uh there will be there will be yeah
I think we can wrap it up as long as
that train is burning there's gonna be
more you folks right good point
Yeehaw out here in my vinyl chloride
oh can I lock me a cocktail with extra
vinyl chloride we need you need to you
need to figure out and work on a
Midwestern accent because you want some
Western accent people
it's like the Oshkosh gosh like Chicago
you know my goodness yeah there you go
from Chicago John Wayne funny at all
yeah Zach
what prove him wrong well you just said
it's not fun I love it it's funny it's
from Chicago you know my good friend
John Wayne Gacy clean yes
my buddy over here no see that's true
like Joe Pesci you gotta think more
Chicago
yeah here is the beautiful East
Palestine East Palestine
um thank you for talking about us so you
thank you thank you I'm so sorry and I
hope you're safe if there's any way we
can help which I want to yeah please
this is insane this is insane it looks
like stranger things yeah right real
it's like the Mind flare yeah
let me tell you there Demi Gorgon comes
after me and ain't gonna be pretty for
him
let me tell you about bananas Zach
let me tell you about Chicago see that
that's for Joe Pesci right there
I said work on it you know there's no
expectation that you'll nail it right
away but I'm just saying
like you're you're you're as long as the
barbecue spot open we ain't got no
problem right you're Louisiana uh kind
of Mississippi guy I heard all the cows
are dropping dead that's good I mean the
price of of bovine be going down I'm not
hitting up the barbecue on discount boy
I'll drive up the price if they're all
done well there's lots of meat available
all this did you oh you're gonna eat the
employee urethane
did you say get up hit up the bovine
that's right like bovine creatures
that's a cow Zach a bovine is a cow yes
oh there's a news to me what did you
think it was wasn't that bovine like
what isn't that like a um
no I'm thinking of a kangaroo kangaroo
is a marsupial yes never mind yeah it
doesn't even sound really unrelated yeah
totally unrelated yeah that'd be a cow
Vine bovine bovine like have more wine
with your bovine herb
anyways way to bring it back come on
would now be a good time to launch a
come to beautiful East Palestine kind of
like travel
come to beautiful you know the timer
does not seem good yeah come to
beautiful East Palestine
very affordable
beautiful Cloudy Skies it's always a
little overcast and East Palestine
today for a cheap cheap price over here
twenty dollars a night
mm-hmm
you need gas masks we got them
that's right
acid rain
the gas masks are going quick though
we don't have many left so hurry up have
you ever been washed clean from rain
and not water like bleach in your skin
sizzles that kind of wash clean
your skin sizzles when it hits you
come on down to East Palestine Ohio
do you remember
um as a kid being told about acid rain
in elementary school all the time yeah
green
I think they uh
I think they addressed that for the most
part although apparently it's back baby
acid rain is back I think it's real but
it does it happens in like it only
happens in like China or India where the
it's like so [__] polluted where it's
like you can't even see well right I I
think it was a real problem but they um
the regulations
worked in that regard and and reduced it
together it's kind of like the the ozone
layer stuff
well if you ever wanted to see acid rain
come on down to East Palestine Ohio
make sure you get a special umbrella
made of steel as vinyl clock will be
burned through immediately but we get
those for you right at the bus stop
um
Eastern Palestine have you ever drank
orange water
well come on down
it's got a nice little flavor minerally
is it like Tang
what orange water is it kind of like
Tang it tastes like tank that's right
like tropical flavor who doesn't love
Tang it could be jerky it's a cell tank
I probably it's hard to find but yeah
they do okay Martin the water uh
sommelier had this to say about our
orange water
all right he's passed out he's dead
no comment from Martin
character water
[Music]
a character
Joe Biden need to come breathe some of
these fumes
all right whatever sorry to them we're
gonna follow it though and I'm gonna
help how I can
we will continue the fight for Palestine
Ohio I just want people to go to jail
and I want people to be held accountable
yeah and I want Joe Biden to go there
and breathe that [__]
and have a [__] Vinyl chloride ice
cone come on man
ice cream with extra vinyl sprinkled on
it
kids used to come up and reach in the
pool
did you say it so confidently it's so so
much purpose
that was one of his favorite stories he
would retell it on the campaign Trail he
was reach into the pool pulling my hairy
legs
and they jump on my lap and the
raining from the sky
that
all right listen
I gotta go
yep thank you guys for watching it's
been a pleasure it's been a joy it's
been a thrill it's been Monday
some people hate Monday not me I get to
come in and spend it with this lovely
crew and this beautiful audience we love
thank you members
Feast tomorrow
because it's see you next Tuesday
and I will see you all on Tuesday
just tomorrow
all right
take care
[Music]
[Applause]